yeah all rise there the Pledge of
Allegiance representative Bale lead us
in the play
join me ining to our
flag flaged
States liy justice for
all thank
you all
right
looks like our clerk is about to show up
all right take all
right thank you for your your short
term as
[Laughter]
clerk
so outstanding
job right here right here did with where
the clerk is you
forget I just you know I did the
clerking last night last time you're the
most valuable person on this
committee I'm the least
valuable like to open uh the uh the
uh SE the uh January 17th uh hearing and
from resources Recreation and
development first before us first B bill
is House Bill
1045 relative to requiring a powerboat
operator the to wear an engine cut off
switch while operating certain power
bolts traveling over head Headway speed
and chair recognizes representative
McDonald speak on the speak on the bill
to introduce the bill the floor is
yours thank you Mr chairman uh John
McDonald I'm the representative for uh
kale district 6 which is the towns of
wolf bro and Tuftonboro
uh EOS engine cut off switch uh back
between 2018 and 2020 uh the federal
government Coast Guard the boting
manufacturer started looking ways they
could possibly uh uh save some lives uh
out on the Waterway and what they came
up with was uh this ecos and uh if you
don't know what that is I've got one in
my pocket if it's okay with you Mr
chairman I'll just pass it around go
right ahead there's a this in here plugs
into the the uh by the shifting lever
and once it pulled is pulled out it
kills the motor this can be worn on your
your jacket your PFD or around your
wrist like this so if you fall out of
the boat this has some certain expansion
this will pull out from the shifter and
kill the
motor and if I can just get that back
from everybody because they won't be
able to stop their boat unless they have
it
so um
so around 2020 uh the federal government
adopted some regulations one that the
manufacturers uh boats after 2020 had to
be manufactured with one of those engine
cut off switches uh so any boat
manufactured after 2020 will have that
automatically no extra cost it's just
put up by the
manufacturer uh some of the Marine
dealers that I spoke to they give
training on new boats and how that works
I wanted to make sure they use it the
right way and also that they can't
startop their bone L is plugged in so uh
what it does uh the benefits of it
prevents unnecessary accidents injuries
and death caused by a boat operator
being unexpectedly thrown from the helm
uh this also includes situations where
the operator is rejected from the boat
which typically leads to a runaway boat
in these scenarios anyone in the water
faces potential propeller cuts and
Strikes the boat can also collide with
the vessels and it also puts uh Mar
Patrol officers in danger and they have
to risk their lives or whatever to go
and try to take control of the boat
um thank you as you can see by the law
itself uh it only applies to boats
manufactured after
2020 uh they have to be less than 26
feet and they can't have an enclosed
cabin other exceptions are if you are in
a boat that's uh less than 26 feet
manufacturing 20121 if you're going
Headway speed say you're trolling or
fishing whatever you don't have to wear
that going into a dock or anything like
that uh I guess that's about the whole
the whole bill and any questions I'll be
GL to try to
answer I'll go s from there and come
come right
back thank you thank you Mr chair um yes
so thank you for taking my question um
the concern I have with this bill is
exactly the Headway speed um language
you know back in I don't have my notes
in front of me but it was 2019 I think
um the New Hampshire law uh was changed
to uh redefine Headway speed it used to
be defined as um the the slowest speed
uh possible to uh maintain steerage or
six miles an hour and then the or six
miles an hour was removed um the there's
I am the reason I'm concerned is exactly
what you brought up which is trolling um
trolling uh people that troll often have
kicker motives right especially for um
salmonoid species and um it's not clear
to me how the um how the cutof switch
would work on those kicker Motors um
those um you know doing a little bit of
research people will troll somewhere
between you know one and a half to up to
three sometimes five I don't think in
New Hampshire maybe but up up to five
miles an hour um and it seems to me
based on the current definition of
Headway speed and the definition in this
bill that that's more um 5 mil hour
would be more than Headway speed so I'm
concerned how this would affect um uh
trolling in particular um if you could
comment on that yes thank uh thank you
for the question the the trolling mtiv
that I've seen are all small horsepower
like two three horsepower somewhere in
there and if you were going under
Headway speed you wouldn't have to have
the the
switch do you see
oh the remaining steerage yeah yeah I
saw that it had Chang for years it was a
six miles per hour and I'm not quite
sure why it was uh why it was changed um
again this is something that uh this
kind of images or mirrors the uh the
federal law and uh I don't know exactly
how many
states have adopted this there some that
have adopted have adopted something
similar what surprised me when I started
looking at this uh you know personal
watercraft they're not required to have
wear one of those the jet skis um they
have them but they're not required to by
law required to wear
one I hope that answered your question
as best I could for a followup thank you
Mr chair um so I did research the
federal law as well the federal law
actually um talks about on plane for
motor boats or I don't know exactly the
term for for sailboats but it's it's
basically based on the the wavelength
for sailboats um which is a big
difference um like there's a lots of
people of course that um on the lake
that where my cap uh Camp is on that you
know put putt around in their pontoon
boats they're not going Headway speed
for sure but they're surely not on plane
either they're going about five miles an
hour or something like that I don't
think that those people would be
particularly impacted by that because
they're not trying to get up and grab a
line and things like that um but the
you mentioned that it's based on the
federal law but there is a substantial
difference between this and the federal
law because the federal law really does
say um uh I'm sorry uh planing you know
planing and I'm wondering why it wasn't
sort of word for word for the federal
law with the federal law this is the the
federal law that I I saw includes these
these facts these these points I haven't
seen the one that you've spoken about uh
it just mentions the the Headway
speed okay thank you uh for taking my
question did you say that if um it comes
out they can't start the uh vote again
did I hear that correctly yes unless
they push it back in okay so what if
they lose
it it fall into the water somehow then
they can't get get where they want to go
well hopefully they have it around their
wrist like or they have it clipped to
their their pants or their bathing suit
or possible life jacket if they really
want to be safe
boers okay the big thing is is if you
think about in the fall there's not a
lot of people out there boting no matter
what lake you're on and if you fall out
of your boat on a boat when it's in gear
you got to pull it out of gear to stop
it to put it in neutral that boat's
going to keep on going this way it pulls
out it shuts down the boat and you can
swim back to the boat and get Board of
the
boat thank thank
you thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking our questions um just a quick
background I've owned a number of these
boats and pretty familiar with those
potentially life-saving devices because
I've fallen off you know fallen out or
fallen off watercraft before um but I'm
also familiar with the what they can
hinder you a bit too especially if you
have to move around your your watercraft
quickly to help somebody or move
somebody or get somebody life jacket or
whatever specifically in the case of I I
want to ask you about the 26 foot rule
my first two Jet Boats were bow Rider
style jet boats that could hold eight or
10 passengers um an 18-footer was was
one and another was a 22-footer and they
were they had large engines in them 350s
uh in board jet drives
um as a prudent voter I think
you're just it's Reckless to not wear
one for your own safety kind of like
riding in my car I would always consider
wearing a seat Bel I always wear a seat
belt in in the
car so my question is how did you get to
26 feet and can you define enclosed
cabin
that's the number that the uh federal
government the Coast Guard the
manufactures came up with 26 20 uh less
than 26 feet uh the big thing to
remember is this only applies to boat's
manufactured after uh 2020 anything
before that wouldn't be required to have
that uh I think in a closed cabin there
pretty
much you know you get a Boston New well
that's not in closed cabin you got some
speed boats that have a roof that would
be enclosed cabin it would have to be up
to
someone's there's some things you can't
really always Define that's perfect but
if you go to court you can Define
explain to the judge what enclosed cabin
is I
think there may be a definition
somewhere in in one of the regulations
to defines that I'm just not aware of it
to be honest with
you so I haven't found an enclosed cabin
definition but I guess what I'm asking
about more specifically are the smaller
boats say a center console with a on top
that or a a smaller boat like my older
boats 18 22 foot where you have a bimin
and you can add sides and things like
that I mean they call that a full
enclosure it's not a hard enclosure is
the idea is the thinking behind that
language to exclude a boat that has
something else that will keep the
operator inside the boat is that what
you mean right yes okay so it doesn't
have to be wall with doors it could
literally
be the you know the canvas and then the
question is do you have to have the
canvas rolled down rolled up anyways I
find that language a little problematic
for all those reasons okay maybe uh
Chief dun Captain duny can explain a
little bit better he's got a lot of
knowledge on that stuff I think I I get
the possibility sorry um I just think
that the language in the bill has to be
fixed careful on the back and forth I
apologize represent R for a question
thank you Mr chair um representative
McDonald I'm really proud to be a
co-sponsor of this bill but one thing
that we didn't discuss is was this uh
the Genesis of this bill due to a
specific incident I know there was a
marac resident um Christine Lavoy and
her friend uh Suzanne fulam who risked
their life to save a a runaway boat I
believe it was last year they were
honored and conquered December 11th was
this was that incident a Genesis of the
spill that it may be there was a an
incident on L wi basaki where uh there
was a runaway boat and two Marine Patrol
officers tried to stop the boat and the
boat ran over their patrol boat flipped
it over and they all wented at the water
I'm not sure if that was the same one
that you're talking about or not okay uh
I think it was off of bear Island uh
last summer I think it was thank
you any other questions uh
MERS of the
committee thank you thank you Mr
chairman representative represent D
ly Captain D
Levy floor is
yours good morning Mr chair honorable
members of the rr&d committee good
morning my name is Tim Dunley I'm uh
representing this morning uh the Marine
Patrol uh unit of the div division of
State Police I come before you this
morning in support of this bill and uh
will say that we've uh worked with
representative McDonald on the language
of this bill as it does closely resemble
the current federal law um
this uh request from Marine Patrol uh
for this bill is a result of years of
circumstances where we are experiencing
runaway boats where the operator for
whatever reason has been ejected from
the boat and the boat continues down the
lake sometimes straight if it has a
power steering mechanism sometimes
performing what we refer to is The
Circle of Death if there's no power
steering uh we see anywhere from six to
12 of these a summer and often times
it's smaller rowboats where a young
child has been distracted ejected while
operating the tiller motor but we've
also see it uh in in larger Craft um and
and the the length of 26 feet mirroring
the federal law is based on statistical
data that the Coast Guard collects every
year looking at Falls overboard and it
is very apparent
overwhelmingly uh these types of
incidents happen on boats under 26 ft
and there therefore you see the language
before you
um you will see within the bill there is
a definition uh for Headway speed as it
as it uh appears currently in voting
statutes um in New Hampshire um planing
is the term that is used at the federal
level uh we used Headway speed because
it is really the speed that leads you up
to a planing speed uh on the water um so
we were looking to use consistent
language as well as an enclosed cabin um
we've defined the enclosed cabin in this
bill and it uh means a space on board a
vessel that is surrounded by bulkheads
and covered by a roof bulkheads are a
rigid uh side and um would prevent
someone from being ejected overboard
that is the purpose representative
McDonald showed you the lanyard type
switch which when you fall overboard or
leave the helm exceed the length of the
lanyard it does Tri trigger button on
the dash next to the shifter that stops
the engine in the event someone is
injured or is overboard and there's
another passenger on board you just flip
that lever that is tripped by the loss
of this lanyard and you can restart the
boat and go around and perform the
rescue if you're by yourself the engine
stops you can perform a self- rescue by
swimming back to the
boat some may think that this lanyard
will become
cumbersome folks they now sell regularly
in installed in our state by marinas a
little chip a fob that can be worn in a
a bracelet it can be worn in a little
pager type device on your belt it can be
just slipped in your pocket so that that
when that operator and you can actually
program the distance from the wheel that
that uh you must break before the engine
will
start they put them often times on dog
vests because we have dogs that fall
overboard passengers wear them you can
have up to four devices per boat
cordless so that if anyone Falls over
including your pet the engine will stop
uh and then can be overridden with a
push of a button on the dash uh but it's
a conscious uh maneuver to be able to
restart the
boat as representative McDonald said we
did have an incident last summer where
Marine Patrol officers uh had a large
boat doing circles after hitting a rock
both passengers were
rejected um the boat was doing about 20
mph erratically it had power steering so
it wasn't just doing circles it was
going in all directions in an attempt to
disable that boat that boat struck the
patrol boat flipped it and the officers
were caught underneath the air bubble
within the underside of their patrol
boat and were dragged about 200 yards
before they were able to get out from
under the patrol boat and the two women
mentioned were the ones that came to the
rescue of the two officers happened
about midnight on Lake wiip Pasad um but
we see I have stories Galore of 12T
rowboats a young girl on Lake uh Winona
in New Hampton the tiller slipped out of
her hand she got ejected it started
doing the Circle she was wearing a life
jacket thank you thank you the prop of
that 9.9 horsepower engine got tangled
up in the straps and the foam of her
jacket and it stalled the engine and her
brother was able to then lift the engine
up uh preventing her from from drowning
so these this happens more often than
than you might be aware and it's it's
just a safety mechanism that now is
convenient for the operator boats many
boats have been equipped with this
device for many years it only has been
since 2020 where the feds are requiring
boat manufacturers to equip it and it's
not only boats but for your smaller
outboard motors the motors themselves
are equipped with this
device I'm happy to answer any questions
that you may have
um we we're looking at this from a
safety point of
view represent
representative Q fail
then thank Mr chairman Mr dunby thanks
so much for um for coming today and
pointing out the enclosed cabin so let
me ask you about that first it mentions
bulkheads bulkheads aren't generally
decide designed to keep people in the
boat it's the gunnel and the and the
height of the freeboard that does that a
bulkhead is typically as you I'm sure
know but for anybody listening or
anybody here in the room who doesn't
have a bunch of boats bulkhead is that
structural part like the door between
the cabin you know down below the
sleeping space and the salon or
something like that so should we change
bulkhead to
gunnel we could but I I first we are
using the the
language um to remain consistent my
concern with just gunnel is that gunnels
only come up to a half three and a half
we don't know the height of a gunnel
depending on the style of the boat um
that sometimes we had a fisherman who
was leaning over tending to a fish and
because of the length of his legs and
the height of his gunnel his feet went
out from under him and he went over um
if the gunnel is high enough to prevent
someone being
ejected um
perhaps that's language we could
use I don't know that it would do it in
all circumstances sir respectfully for a
followup the the followup is um you
mentioned this happens a lot and and we
hear about it anecdotally and we don't
like knee-jerk you know one kind of
thing like one traffic accident we
should pass a seat Bel law or something
like that of course we have a lot of
traffic accidents um so I'm really
curious how many how do you enforce it
like how many violations do you think
you're going to issue because of this
will your current staff enforce that and
where is the fiscal
note um from an enforcement perspective
first of all we have it depends on the
season obviously but we have I would say
between six and 12 a year where this
happens um from an enforcement
perspective this isn't something that
officers are going to be just stopping
boats randomly to check for their
lanyard I I see this as an enforcement
action that
happens either post accident or incident
or at the time of a a vessel stop uh
it's it's it would be very rare that an
officer from a distance could see this
violation occurring because it's it's
it's hard to see
um it is it is an issue that um I would
say at least six times a year around our
state and oftentimes
more oh let me go
around then we'll come back if you have
another
question representative Vale and
representative organ what happened to
your your your name tag your name plate
oh there it is now I can see it oh yeah
these are glasses okay
thank thank you Mr chair um thank you
Captain Dunley for taking my
question um so I'm just looking at mine
for the bill engine cut off
switch so there's a list of devices here
would that include every kind of device
that we would be using IF to call it an
ecos so for example you have a lowte
version of an ecos on the table but you
also have the chip which is more of a
high tech way so I just want to make
sure this covers everything because
sometimes when I see lists I think what
if something's not on
there I I understand your question
representative and uh yes it would
include all if if uh you would like to
to amend the language to to add a phrase
or similar devices if you're more
comfortable with that we are certainly
fine with
that thank you for taking my question
certainly representative pan thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question uh with regard to the uh switch
if is there a penalty aspect to this if
I jury rig the boat so that that thing
is in position but I'm I'm not attached
to it and you have an in and there's an
incident uh what happens
then I would representative it's a good
question and I would have to check I
believe there is a catchall statute that
refers to violations within this chapter
will be a violation or penalties so it
would be a violation with an
undetermined uh fine set by the
court thank
you representative
McHugh did you have a you had a question
and
then okay representative Derby thank you
Mr chair um thank you um Captain Dy
would you be at all amenable to um
excluding trolling from this language
somehow I think by current definition of
Headway speed uh it is so you're looking
to include trolling in the requirement
no to exclude trolling from requiring an
EOS I believe it's already ex uh
Exempted um the Headway speed statute uh
says not to uh Headway speed is a
minimum well it's it's it's before you
um exactly as it appears in other
sections of uh the statute um it allows
for the maintaining of steerage I can
tell you that the reason that language
exists is because some of our currents
on our Sea Coast exed 6 miles hour and
we were having difficulty uh with boats
having to uh obey a law for Speed under
bridges at Headway speed when the
current was doing more than that more
than six Inland water we do not see this
as an issue majority of boats can
achieve Headway speed well below six
miles per hour um and and
certainly perhaps on the Sea Coast funa
or something like that any fish that
you're looking to catch in our state is
going to be well below that um so I I I
I I'm I would happy to
entertain trolling uh being Exempted
under six miles per hour um it certainly
achieves the same thing thank
you any other questions by members of
the committee
representative thanks for taking another
question
um I know when I operate my
outboard
it's that device is I think on one of
them is I can't start the motor because
it's I think uh got some electronic
coating on it but another one I could
definitely start it but there's nothing
that says I have to connect it to me or
anything else and I usually have a put
my Wrist through it as I grab the tiller
but that doesn't I mean is there is
there something in here that talks about
uh or that should talk about the proper
use of it because I think like someone
someone else just mentioned you can
connect it start it you're using it but
it's not really being used properly
because because it's not connected to
the operator right uh I think um the
Roman two uh starting at line 11
requires that uh any boat with um
horsepower must be wearing the wearing
okay thank
you I can respectfully if I may yes Mr
chairman I recognize that this statute
some may look at this as a helmet law or
seat belt law um we tend to look at it
from a Marine Patrol perspective similar
to the snowmobile skimming law it is the
after effect that happens when somebody
is ejected and that boat is running
loose it's not only endangering the
operator but it's also and we've had
this we have this happen if we are
unable to get there in time and disable
that boat it is ultimately landing on
Shore it's endangering swimmers
docks property um and First Responders
who are trying to float a floating line
that hopefully the propeller catches
installs the motor we've had boats that
we we partially hook onto the engine it
changes the direction of the uh the
motor and suddenly that robo's a rocket
ship heading for sure somewhere so it's
it's the after effects that often times
whether it's endangering the operator or
those responding or those who are
victims on Shore uh We've seen all of
that thank you for that opportuni any
other question by members of the
committee uh I do have one question I
think it follows on to representative
Horgan question on
enforcement uh is you say that this is
in a list would be in a list
of uh
infractions uh and what what would be
the uh what of not doing this what would
be the uh the penalty in in a general
sense it would be the lowest level of
penalties a violation like not wearing
your life jacket uh viol violation level
offense with a fine set by the court
okay and if if this is a continuous
thing is there somebody refuses and it's
builds up you know habitual offender is
there something beyond that in the and
even just in general sure uh right now
there are no points attached to voting
violations other than voting well
intoxicated uh so multiple offenses we
would have to ultimately see that this
person is is truly um in
intentionally uh ignoring the law and at
that point we might have to go after
something administratively but would it
would have to be after multiple
violations and and final question is
would it be
uh how does if somebody if somebody
falls out of the boat and this happens
okay we got you but how do you uh how do
we enforce it in a in a prior situation
where the person's not wearing it but
you you don't you're not going to see
them from uh from another boat how how
does the officer uh able to know that
somebody is or is not wearing this
especially if you have those uh those
electronic ones uh there is a challenge
but I will tell you that you would be
surprised and and for those of you who
are voters it's amazing the number of
people you see who are operating boats
who will step away from the steering and
the helm to oh to do different things
about the boat as the boats going down
the lake that is where
I Envision us making stop op s for this
um aside from coming upon it after the
fact I got
you
representative all right so that last
part you just said is different than
what you said previously so you just
said you do Envision making stops as a
primary violation for it in that
circumstance if you see somebody
standing two feet away from the helm so
you Invision stopping them and enforcing
and and then letting the court set a
random fine that we don't know what that
fine is
because you see somebody one foot away
with their hand off the hel uh
representative I am fine if you would
like to amend this and and put language
in there that it's a secondary offense
and we wouldn't be able to primarily
stop people for that that that's fine um
as as uh the chair uh questioned you
know when when could we see it there are
times when we see people who are walking
about their boat um away from the helm
uh but but your wishes we serve
certainly would our ultimate goal is to
see people wearing
these representative Derby for a final
question I hope yes thank you very very
briefly um but it appears actually that
with the fob that they'd actually be in
compliance walking around because like
you said there's a there's a you know
there's a degree of Freedom that's
provided and in fact with the fob it
seems like it would be impossible to
stop some body we if we assume that the
fob were in use it' be impossible to
stop somebody because it might just be
in their pocket in the circumstance of
the fob I I would agree with you sir yes
sir I representative you add your hand
up if you want if you have a question
and a question then I'll get blind in
um W with the fob and a stop being made
all they have to do is produce the the
fob and say they have the cut off switch
if they're thrown out is that correct
yes but if uh when you have the fob you
have a display on your dashboard that
actually tells you your distance um that
you can leave uh where it's programmed
and you can actually see if there's
multiple fobs on the boat say for the
dog um the the primary fob is the
operator fob and that limits you to a
certain distance from that that main
reader the passenger f fobs can be
greater distances um can they swap fobs
absolutely but there is a display
showing that information thank
you seeing no other questions thank you
very
much me uh I think that's it call thank
you for your time okay just uh just a
reminder that we are do doing exing next
week so this bill will be on the uh
exing if if you have any
amendments get them in this uh so we can
discuss them best to get amendments in
be before the the executive session
because then things are able to proceed
with more speed with that I will close
the
hearing and the next
uh next hearing is at 10 o'clock you got
minutes
starting hearing on on House Bill 1040 9
relative to Prohibition of overnight
Ming of house
boats representative
Griffin the floor is
yours Mr chairman thank you Mr chairman
and honorable members of the committee
my name is Gerald Griffin and I'm
currently serve as the vice chair of the
joint committee on audit and oversight I
am a member of the finance committee and
division one of that committee and I
also serve as an alternate on the fiscal
committee I represent Hillsboro 42 the
towns of Libo mon Veron and New
Boston House Bill 1049 is the result of
a request from some of my conu
constituents many of which are here
today it is a b bipartisan bill that I
strongly endorse and wholeheartedly
support I say
bipartisan because there are three of us
on there myself as sponsor one
Republican and one Democrat who joins us
today representative
Lehman I am sure that this committee's
members are familiar with the concept of
a Great Bond under that concept all
bodies of water within this state in
excess of 10 acres a held in trust for
the public that concept is well
rooted in common law and has always been
the rule in New Hampshire dating back to
Colonial
times this bill is about the concept and
the trust that it
creates 1049 could not be more simple
the bill deletes section three of RSA
270-a use of house boats section one of
that
bill section one of that law defines the
terms
used in its simplest term a house boat
is any craft with sleeping and toilet
facilities section two of the law
protects the land owners AB buding a
great boat on and we all wholeheartedly
support that section and their
rights section three of the current law
prohibits watercraft with sleeping and
toilet facilities from overnighting on a
great
Pond section three of RSA
270a is in my opinion in direct conflict
with the concept of a Great
Bond
with the concept of a Great Pond and the
waters being held for trust in trust for
the use of the public I don't believe
that that lell concept was intended only
for the daylight hours to my knowledge
none of the other New England states
have any such
prohibition I have tried to put this
proposal in the lofty context
of our state being a trustee for the
public I'm sure other speakers who
actually own boats will deal with the
more practical side of both the current
section three and our
proposal please vote
OTP and send the proposal to the Full
House for its
consideration thank you I'm happy to
answer any questions you may
have any questions by represent
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
um thank you representative for taking
my question um would you uh expect that
this change in the law would permit um
overnight house boats um occupied
overnight house boats and if so would it
be multiple nights in a row would that
be permitted as
well thank you for asking that question
when when I um propose a draft for law I
thought about adding a lot of things to
it but everything I thought about adding
basically is already in voting law
either in this law or some other voting
law uh the one area that I thought the
committee might want to consider and
that we would not be opposed to would be
Amendment an amendment that said that uh
you could only overnight for say three
or four consecutive days in a month that
would prevent anyone from trying to take
up residence on the
lake representative rung for for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um so Suppose
there is uh someone who's staying on the
house boat for three or four consecutive
nights but they're renting it like it
they're using it as an
Airbnb um would you suppose that they
would be obliged to pay rooms and Mills
tax which is currently levied against
airbnbs on
land I guess we'd have to look to the
detail of that law but I would think so
okay thank
you any other questions by members of
the
committee representative wolf you look
like you're ready okay thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question do you have any references to
somebody that may be out there for a
lengthy period of time if you're talking
two or three days with toilet
facilities excuse me toilet
facilities um the whole definition of a
house boat is currently contained in the
law uh requires that the boat have
toilet facilities sanitary facilities
and sleeping facilities so U I guess uh
we could look to the current definition
and we're not proposing to change that
definition or a
followup I'm not familiar with the
current law but does that mean that if
you're staying overnight you have to
have toilet facilities on the boat it
does indeed thank
youn the cour thank you chair um this is
rather could be indelicate uh we had a
bill uh
representative last term that had to do
with house boats uh on great ponds and
uh the gist of the
bill well it the the the reason for
bringing it Forward was that the the
toilet facilities which are adequate uh
is a rather loose definition I believe
in a lot of circumstances
and to be to be blunted can be just a
bucket um so that's
um do you have any information about
what sort of toilet facilities are
required because I think that's the some
of the issue here at hand thank
you uh I'll be very honest I haven't I
haven't done any boating for many many
years um so I'm not an expert on on
boating and the and the facilities but
uh I would look to the law for the
definition of the of what what
facilities are required and if those are
inadequate we certainly would be uh you
know we'd be amendable to making them
adequate I could speak
on me do okay all right okay we'll we'll
get
to anyone else for a question uh
of the
representative seeing none thank you
very much thank you Mr chair and
honorable
members chair recognizes Tim dunlevy
representing the Marine
Patrol uh who is uh signs in as
neutral thank you Mr chair honorable
members of the R&D committee again my
name is Tim dun Ley I come before you
today uh on behalf of the the New
Hampshire Marine Patrol uh the
department is neutral on this uh bill as
it is uh proposed to you today however
we did want to bring to your attention
as
submitted um this is going to allow uh
anyone who chooses to vacation in our
state or residence to come up drop
anchor overnight on any of our Inland
Waters and spend the day the week the
month the summer
uh in oftentimes and it it is not
allowed in normally traveled portions of
the lake so it forces folks to drop
their anchor close to
shore uh our concern uh that we wanted
to bring to you is the shorefront
property owner Boer conflicts that
certainly will increase uh and put
demands on our agency uh it is uh
difficult to enforce with the number of
officers that we have
statewide um and we we have seen and we
do see people who just don't realize
that they can't just come and sleep on
their boat in New
Hampshire our laws do currently allow
for sleeping on board your boat if you
have a Nexus to Shore and some might
carry that forward and and um that means
they have access to a toilet but if you
are tied to Shore or anchored AB budding
a person's property with their
permission it is allowed and you also
have to report to Dees uh the reason for
that is so that if there is a toilet on
board and the boat comes from out of
state they will inspect the Marine
sanitation device or the marine toilet
uh Plumbing uh in New Hampshire it is
illegal to allow your uh device to be
plumbed in such a way that you can
discharge overboard it requires you to
pump in New Hampshire so those are some
of the issues that that we see as an
agency that this bill uh May
inadvertently create uh with who knows
how many people who will now avoid the
hotel charge and sleep on their boat on
our Lakes happy to answer any questions
you may
have start from this side fir
first uh yeah representative
first thank you for taking my question
uh can you clarify what you just said we
currently have a law that allows the
toilet facilities to be inspected in
this same chapter
um a boat that is anchored a budding
Shore or uh attached to shore could be a
dock or just a a rope to a tree with the
owner's permission is allowable if they
have contacted Dees to notify them of
that practice it's just a phone call or
an email to
Dees um Dees has a statute and and uh
when you register your boat in New
Hampshire if you have toilet facilities
there's a box that is checked at the
time of registration and Dees has people
that will go around to marinas uh and
actually inspect house boats making sure
that that uh Black Water gray water
can't be discharged overboard the
plumbing needs to be disabled uh only
allowing you to pump it at an approve
facility representative wolf and folks
on this side thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question um
if you're allowed to be on the boat for
an indeterminate length of time do you
come under the local zoning ordinance as
an accessory dwelling unit or what
happens in that case I I can't speak
directly to that representative uh I do
know in some other uh cases involving
boats restaurant style boats zoning did
not
apply when they were on state
waters okay representative Darby was
there anyone else on his side thank you
Mr chair thank you Captain D Ley again
I'm just trying to understand how to
interpret um the law a little bit here
because 20 uh 270 A2 says that um you
can uh you are permitted to you know
ground or Beach um or tie your boat to
shore um overnight if you basically if
you own that or if you have the owner's
permission um 270 A3 says you can't
accept as permitted by
2782 um the 2785 says if you're in
violation that's where the penalties
occur so the I this is a genuine
question I don't know how to interpret
this law two says you can do this three
says you can't do it except as perimed
by two and then five says you get
penalized if you violate it so is it is
it your interpretation that by removing
uh A3 that you could tie to um to shore
and you could tie the shore any place
because it's it's not permitted that
would be my interpretation yes sir okay
thank
you any other
questions representative
gold uh does this just apply to a house
bow which I picture as being sort of
with P pontoons and just a square kind
of uh structure or does it uh could it
apply to a 35 foot
nice
vote that's an excellent question
representative and I can tell you that
historically uh the courts at least
where we have brought these cases before
them um as as uh representative Harve
Harvey bullia said um the courts have
ruled that even a small ski booat with a
sleeping bag and a five gallon bucket
intended for that purpose has been
deemed a house boat not all and and to
be open with you that's not typically
what we see at anchor but removing A2
certainly opens that as the type of boat
that could in addition to the
traditional Health votes that we
see any no other any other
questions seeing none very much thank
you for your
time
okay uh Tom uh Wally uh
presume is a rep I guess representating
himself speak for five
minutes hi
my y turn it on okay uh my name is Tom
Wally and I'd like to talk in favor of
HB 1049 I live in Mont New Hampshire and
I have a small 19t house boat that I can
trailer to different bodies of water
when I got it several years ago I was
asked where I want to plan on taking it
and I responded I would like to Anchor
in a secluded Cove in several lakes near
me and that's when I was informed that
uh New Hampshire is the only state in
the country where it's illegal to spend
the night on a boat on inland waterways
this came as a surprise to me so I Char
started checking around to see if this
was true in other states I called Maine
inland fisheries and asked them if I
could spend the night on the lake in
Maine they said no problem as long as
they had the correct lights uh anchor
lights and I did not anchor in the main
Channel I also could not tie up on
private land but the rest of the lake
was public water and there was no
restrictions I then contacted Vermont
Massachusetts New York Connecticut and
none of none of them had such laws asked
him if they had issues with people
spending the night on the boats and they
said they did not I've taken many
overnight trips to seago Lake in Maine
and I've only ever seen one other boat
moing overnight on that
Lake I then looked up the Marine laws in
all 50 states is it uh took me quite a
while and New Hampshire is the only
state that bans overnight stays on the
boat I spent days on the Eerie Canal in
new New York I have uh gone to lakes in
Maine spent times on lake in North
Carolina and trailered my boat down to
the St John's river river in Florida the
only state that I can't stay on my boat
overnight is my own home state of New
Hampshire I wanted to find out more
about the origins of the law of RSA 270
a-3 how it came about so I went to the
state archives and I looked up notes on
the original Hearing in
1967 the notes from the hearing stated
two reasons for the law to prevent house
quotes from being used as living
quarters and to prevent pollution waste
being thrown
overboard so rather than coming up with
rules to address these concerns such as
limits on how many nights you could stay
on your boat are designating what type
of sanitary facilities you had on your
boat they just outlawed spending the
night on the boat
outright as the law stands I can spend
the night on my boat in public Waters
next to private land if I have
permission of the land owner I don't
understand how only land owners can give
permission for someone using public
Waters the waters belong to the people
of New Hampshire not the lakefront
property owners as far as pollution is
concerned I can stay on my boat
overnight with land owners permission if
I contact the New Hampshire Department
of Environmental Services and get their
permission one time I stayed on Mary
meaton Lake because I have a friend who
owns property there when I contacted New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
surfaces they told me what type of I
told them what type of toilet I had on
my boat and they said it was fine and
gave me permission almost all boats
operating during the day in New
Hampshire and inland waterways do not
have approved toilets on them so how is
my boat with an approved toilet an
environmental concern if preventing
people from living on a boat in
pollution are the reasons for the law it
seems there's much better ways to
address these concerns than a total
ban this is about who and how people can
use public Waters they are just that
public Waters the state does not prevent
the use of public Waters during the day
we can't do that because the waters
belong to everyone they are our resource
and this is what every other state in
the country understands the lakes and
rivers in New Hampshire are public
Waters so why is New Hampshire the LI
fre or die State the only state that
restricts its residents from using the
public Waters at night if anyone has any
questions I'll be glad to
answer any questions by members of the
committee seeing
none thank
you last Andrew
braver Pres bra is a b not an r b okay
thank you okay for five minutes so I am
here reading this on behalf of a
neighbor of mine I do not own a boat he
could not make it fortunately um so I'm
reading it in his place my name is Sam
hinley and I reside at nine Ridgeway
road mont Vernon New Hampshire I have
been a resident of New Hampshire since
2006 and have been the owner of a number
of cruising sailboats throughout the
time I have lived here I am writing to
communicate my support for House Bill
1049 I currently own a small trailerable
catboat with a Cy cabin suitable for
short cruises and overnight stays as
well as a larger cruising sailboat that
I keep on Coastal waterways when I first
bought my catbat to New Hampshire I
began to research options for weekend
trips where my sons and I could spend a
night or two aboard in the peace and
beauty of one of our state's many
navigable inland
waterways I became aware of New
Hampshire's prohibition of overnight
stays during this research and I was
surprised and dismayed at this
exceptionally restrictive law what I
also found during this research is that
the allowable exception to be more to a
private lakefront property in practice
means that unless you have a personal
connection with the landowner you are
limited to the relatively few private
marinas these marinas are sparse or
non-existent on smaller Lakes but even
on the larger Lakes what I found is that
very few have provision for in quote
transient short-term dockage as well as
almost all are full with seasonal
renters what this means in practice is
that any New Hampshire boat owner
wanting to sleep aboard their boat on
our inland waterways must commit to a
season-long contract with the marina
this is both costly and highly
restrictive and what it has meant for me
and my family is that we have taken our
trips out of state to areas where more
reasonable Waterway management POS with
with more reasonable Waterway management
policies as far as I aware New Hampshire
is the only state with such a blank
thank
you uh all right hold on hold on uh do
first of all is there any questions by
members of the
committee also do you have copies of
that testimony that uh might be able to
submit you can
either D it in now for for the yeah just
to the uh to the clerk but no just just
you can you can walk forward we I trust
you first time
here good well like everybody else
everybody else you know you can uh
here's his pin card oh uh yes he was
Andrew rer right here oh
yeah okay you have that one the same
okay okay
good so that's got two more uh the only
other
uh if you want to have that you can mail
it in as well email it to the rest of
the committee if you wish but uh it's
it's in the record now
uh there was by the way was there any
other questions I don't think there was
uh you got to yes okay you want to take
the seat again no which one which
individual you want he's just reading so
I'm not sure he could answer any
questions yeah I I'm actually asking the
committee I'm curious yep
if I'm not sure of of uh many people
know how ungodly expensive motorcycles
are um and I was wondering about whether
the local Hell's Angels decided to grab
a bunch of boats put a five gallon
bucket on it and throw a sleeping bag in
it and then Park them all together in
the middle of the
lake uh
that's that's well that's that's uh
that's you're you're testifying that's
uh what you're doing now is you're just
that's to wait for when we EXA the
committee okay yeah other words it's uh
we here we here we hear questions of
witnesses and that's that's what we do
at a hear okay right realize that
okay uh is there anyone any other
questions of witness anyone who wishes
to
testify which
case I will adjourn the hearing on House
Bill
1049 thank you very much thank you by by
the way uh just for the committee this
we next week we were are going to be
doing some executing and this bill is on
the on that so if you have any any
amendments or something like that be
aware and please get the
pardon
uh yeah back here be back for
e
let's get started open
the open the hearing on uh
House Bill
1060 relative to establishing a geologic
resources
committee representative Bixby floor is
yours yes thank you for the record I'm
representative Peter Bixby from
Dover and uh this bill is a request from
the Department uh and uh what it
essentially does is um
it create it's uh the geological mapping
program in
uh hold
on wrong thing um the geological mapping
program in uh the New Hampshire
Geological Survey uh is supported by um
funds from the uh uh us G Geological
Survey and USGS rules require that
states have a state mapping advisory
committee in order to receive the
funding the New Hampshire geological
resources advisory committee serves this
role now and this is a committee that uh
has been going on for a while but it's
an ad hoc committee and it needs to be
uh revised reauthorized every three
years by the governor uh under RSA uh
21g col 11 uh this bill would uh change
it from being an ad hoc committee to
being a permanent Committee in statute
uh which will assure ongoing funding and
uh will just simplify the process of not
having to have it reauthorized every 3
years uh there is a sunset in the bill
in case Federal funding is terminated
and if you uh and that's basically what
I know about it so if you have any
questions other than the than about the
uh Sunset then I'm going to uh let Miss
Mr cheeky take care of
that
okay representative R for a question yes
thank you Mr chair representative I have
a question on line two on um page you
know page one the bill starts it has
amend RSA 12- is that a zero or an O uh
I'm not sure oh
okay probably probably an O because just
because of the structure of uh of our
okay thank
you is there any other
questions seeing none you're
lucky should be
prasy yes don't say don't say easier I'm
going to hear about well how come you
took an hour
so okay Mr
Shiki from representing New Hampshire
DEA six to eight
minutes the floor is
yours thank you uh for the record my
name is Shane chicki I'm the state
geologist and director of the New
Hampshire Geological Survey at the
Department of Environmental Services as
representative Bixby noted uh we
requested this legislation and the
Department of Environmental Services
fully supports this bill um the New
Hampshire Geological Survey we're a unit
of the office of the commissioner at
Dees uh we receive federal funding each
year from the USGS uh United States
Geological Survey National Cooperative
geologic mapping program and that
funding supports the compilate the
collection of data and production of
geologic maps to uh characterize both
the surficial geology and Bedrock
geology of the State of New Hampshire uh
these maps and the data on them not only
is used by units throughout the
Department of Environmental
Services uh to support groundwater
characterization um and other
environmental parameters but it is used
by Consultants it's used by citizens
it's used by the educational Community
both the uh K through 12 and uh
University communities uh the data
supports uh decision making to support
Homeland Security emergency management
in the aftermath of disaster events
specifically related to flooding um so
the the maps produced from this data
collection supports a wide variety of
uses across the state and local
governments as well um the the program
in federal law does require a a state
mapping advisory committee in order to
receive the federal money the state
mapping advisory committee which is
specified in federal law means that in
order to apply for the Federal grant
funds every year we have to have a
committee of stakeholders who represent
the users of geologic maps that achieves
a cross-section of of those users and
those of interest in the maps and the
data on them to determine the state's
mapping priorities where in the state
we're going to map for a given uh Grant
application and to vote on our grant
proposals uh for many years uh this has
been uh carried out by What's called the
geologic resources advisory committee
the national Cooperative geologic
mapping program has been in effect since
1992 and since that time the geologic
resources advisory committee has
functioned each year in an ad hoc manner
in
2021 the Department of Environmental
Services started to take a look at gr to
take a look at its membership and try to
broaden it and to to to make it as
representative as possible of who uses
our geologic Maps while simultaneously
starting to plot out the future of
geologic mapping in New Hampshire for
the 21st
century as a result of that process our
department legal council reviewed the
composition of grck and determined that
it was not functioning in uh consistency
with RSA 21g section1 as uh
representative bixie mentioned which is
the state law that governs advisory
committees which states that uh advisory
committees need to be created by the
commissioner of an agency in
consultation with the governor uh which
we we completed in 2022 to meet
consistency with that state law the
state law does also say that a uh
advisory committee created has to sunset
in three years upon its creation so the
current rendition of grck now sunsets on
June 30th of
2025 so we are requesting to put this in
statute uh with the membership as
identified in the bill uh which is the
current membership of gr as established
by the commissioner last year uh so that
as representative bixie mentioned we can
continue to receive federal funds each
year and have a standing committee that
represents the cross-section of users of
these Maps across the state both in
state government uh University committee
uh PRI private sector as well as the
representatives of the public uh in
order so that we can continue to receive
these funds currently we have at a a
more detailed scale the 1 to 24,000
mapping scale we have approximately
67,000 67,000 67% of the state mapped
for official geology uh much of Western
New Hampshire has not been mapped to
this point and we have approximately uh
37% of the give you the exact number 23%
of the state mapped for Bedrock geology
at the one in 24,000 scale and we're
looking to move to more populated areas
of the state moving forward so the
language of House Bill 1060 is
consistent with the language that is in
the federal law which requires us to
have a GE State mapping advisory
committee which for us is the geologic
resource advisory committee and if you
look at the federal law um some of the
language that it requires of States
we've put right in the the bill language
which would go into statute so there is
consistency there so again the
Department of Environmental Services is
fully supports this bill uh we feel that
this will uh streamline the process make
things easier for us moving forward
allow us to continue to receive federal
funding and ensure that we are
continually consistent with the state
law that governs advisory committees and
with that we we respectfully request
your approval thank
you I have any questions from I start go
this way this time representative Rong
then
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um I
actually have two one um how successful
are you filling these positions on your
committee so currently so there there's
basically two broad groupings there's
the state agency members and then there
are the external members to state
government the external members to state
government have basically been able to
be completely filled we've not had
trouble with those on the state agency
side we do have a couple vacancies
because as I think you're aware there
been there's been a lot of Shifting in
state government there's been open
positions so for example the divisional
home and Security emergency management
seat is currently open uh however with
this process being completed we will be
able to to move forward and fill that
position likely with the state haard
mitigation officer so by and large we
have been able to fill most of these
positions okay thank you followup Mr
chair follow and then um you mentioned
earlier and I should be more aware of
more educated on it about that committee
bill that's in RSA that limits
committees to a three threeyear
Sunset um with with this committee still
have to follow that sun setting rule or
would it need an amendment to make sure
it was exempt from that RSA my
understanding from our department legal
councel is that based on that law
without us putting this Committee in
statute it sunsets on June 30th 2025
which is the three-year Mark after it
was created in 2022 that is what our
legal councel has
said okay so um but with this if this
passes then it's exempt from that RSA
the sunset correct because it will be
its own committee like other advisory
committees in State Statute okay thank
you okay representative Derby then
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question um is I
understand the uh the federal um rule
federal law um this is you know the
geological resource committee per uh or
sorry the national Cooperative
geological mapping program and in
particular the state map this seems to
be the state map program that is correct
um it it says that the funds have to be
matched um the federal funds have to be
matched that is correct so these this is
these are existing funds you already the
the dees already has funds for this
mapping process so for it's a 5050 match
which means for every Federal dollar we
receive we have to match it for a state
dollar the state dollar comes from
General funded position
within the New Hampshire Geological
Survey
representative thank you Mr chair um
thank you for taking my question so I
might have missed this in your um
testimony but um the list of members for
the committee including state agencies
is this in a direct mirror or who is of
who is on the committee on the ad hoc
committee
yes with with with one addition
um and that is that we've added and this
was a result of a discussion we had with
the current geologic resources advisory
committee now we have added a
representative of the New Hampshire
Association of conservation commissions
and we've had conversations with them
and they are supportive of that so that
will bring in the conservation Community
because there are conservation
commissions who have used this
information thank you that's thank you
that's very helpful
thank you any other questions by members
of the committee representative Derby
for a second thank you Mr chair thanks
again for taking my question um very
similar question to representative Vale
um number of these positions have um are
nominated by a group and then but it
says appointed by the government
Governor I'm sorry um and I don't see an
expiration term for any of the positions
appointed by the governor and so my
question um is how does the process work
and um isn't there normally some type of
expiration for those types of positions
thank you um so for this this is for
this is our proposal for the design of
this committee uh basically it's
basically designed to function as gr
which was authorized under RSA 21g
section 11 currently functions um the
amount of money that we receive each
year from state map is on a good year we
might receive over $100,000 but
generally speaking we receive between 60
and $100,000 depending on what the
proposal is and what the geologic
mapping program at the federal level has
available so the committee meets once a
year um as in reference to your question
we are able to fill these
positions um but it does require a
certain amount of recruiting to be able
to have the people to fill these
positions
so the idea is that when we have people
on there that are representative that
allows them to to be there as as long as
needed hope that helps
yeah any other members of the committee
have a
question the chair I just specifically
ask uh uh as members of the these
committees uh they will the members of
the committee they they were they'll
serve at the uh uh at the prerogative of
the of the
uh of the PE of the of
the whoever uh appoints them correct so
as this is currently written once a
person is appointed this does not
currently have a provision for
necessarily their
termination uh
basically how gr has historically oper
ated because it was ad hoc is that the
state geologist would find individuals
to try to achieve a cross-section they
would serve on gra gr typically meets
once a year to discuss mapping
priorities and approve the annual
proposal to
USGS they would typically remain on gra
as long as they had the interest or as
long as they were employed with the
current organization they were
with that's the history and this and
this uh this automat this well this uh
committee automatically
terminates when the funding stops
through the national Cooperative
geologic mapping program the US
Geological Survey
so that it's that's an
automatic disappear it automatically
disappears or it's no longer functional
if if the national Cooperative geologic
mapping program either ceased to exist
or federal funding was no longer
available under the program that is
correct right but if the federal funding
becomes available under another program
you'd have to come back to re to redo
the
stat as this is currently written I
believe you are
correct y when I also notice that you
have you do not have any uh uh anyone
anyone one from any from the houses of
the
legislature and so that makes it a
better chance of this
passing and it is the truth
so thank you very
much uh question I'll I'll U anyone else
have a question anyone else wish to
testify not I'll call the I'll adjourn
the hearing of want I have
a inquiry to the uh ranking member you
want would you think it's appropriate to
uh dispose of this
now or would you want to we I me know we
are it will be up tomorrow uh next week
so
uh we can we we did last week we
took how
was on Executive right
now well your call my
Call are we all voting in the same
direction it's good
question all right
about when are
we but
uh yeah both
we do most of our work by consensus I
would like to say pardon we do most of
our work by consensus yeah uh so I mean
I would ask for just just the straw
Brook show a hands who might be
interested in who would be for passage
of this
bill do we want to just do it we want to
go into executive session and uh sure
take care of it right now yeah yeah
let's do
that time all right we are so uh I I
think I have ad Jour this the meeting
I'll I'll open a executive session on
House Bill 10 uh
1060 right
yes all right and then give us a chance
to switch mode
well I'll ask for a motion but remember
you got have to write
the write the committee
report that's all right Mr chair I would
like to move um on to pass on House Bill
1060 a second from
representative Derby SEC
for vote by representative run
um you like to speak to you thank you Mr
chair I I think the the testimony we
received from the prime sponsor and the
geologist from Dees made it clear that
this committee is important for us to
support the geographic mapping of New
Hampshire to secure the federal funds um
so I I'd like to encourage the um
committee to support the
motion you like to speak to your second
nothing additional thank you Mr
chair anyone else wish to speak to the
motion thing
no represent representative
wolf just a technical question
representative rung you said
Geographic work of the committee I think
you mean geological thank you thank you
representa very good uh any other one
with any other questions or any other me
any other comments from members of the
committee seeing none on House Bill 1060
will the clerk please call the role
yes all right uh we're going to start
with representative
gold yes okay uh representative gold
votes yes representative Horgan yes the
clerk votes yes representative Healey
yes
representative wolf
yes representative
MCU no he's not here not here okay
representative Donnelly
yes uh representative Dunn yes
representative Vale yes representative
Rong yes representative Kelly is not
here uh representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
hoit yes representative lontine yes
representative love it yes
representative Ryan is not here and
representative rulu
yes okay the motion passes but I see so
we're
missing 16 16 yes
zero nay
thanks what you put that on the consent
calendar 16 to zero obviously
consent okay and uh when can I have the
report I will have it to you at one
o'clock Mr chair very good very good it
it may it may even get into the calendar
May very good appreciate that uh I will
call the uh
that's call the executive session on
as end it thank you very much see we're
now all of a sudden we're quicking the
representative Bixby is there going
amazing it helps to have a bill right
before lunch
too that
was oh you did
oh
see
that you know exactly it's that it's
that
is I know I know you're you're down
Beyond you is the there's a one of the
what was it those antennas that that
broadcast things and goes right through
to
me
e
more coming incoming thank you these are
all well those are two that are for
which side this is for this dis spill we
on now this is
Rose
get
started all right like to call the
meeting to order on House Bill
113 relative to revising the penalties
of the shoreline protection
act uh you haven't if you wish to speak
on the bill fill out a pink card and
send it on up
otherwise speak you forever hold your
peace let's
go uh who is uh let's see who is the
sponsor of the bill representative rung
will you introduce the bill
please thank you Mr chair and thank you
for the committee members I'm very
pleased to introduce House Bill 1103 to
you it's actually a very simple bill
if you look on page one of the bill um
it's just making a revision to um uh the
shorline protection uh water protection
act under RSA
Department of the violation fails to
make a good faith effort at remediation
and
restoration um what people uh
stakeholders around lakes in New
Hampshire and other waterways have
noticed um since the shoreline
protection act this this ver this uh
statute was passed is that it's almost
impossible for Dees to enforce it
because to demon it's one thing to be
able to demonstrate that a violation has
occurred but it's nearly impossible to
um pinpoint damage to a Waterway based
on that one specific violation and I'll
give you an example suppose someone
clearcuts all of the trees in in the
vegetation um in front of their
waterfront that's within that Shoreline
protection Zone that's going to cause
damage to the lake or river eventually
because it's going to encourage runoff
it's going to encourage erosion which is
thus going to allow more nutrients to go
into the lake that may spur CYO bacteria
blooms or other other alile blooms or
just really impact the water quality um
and so that may take years for that to
observe and by then it's really
difficult to say oh it was because of
this one action and also damage to
waterways are cumulative
so damage could be significant not just
from that violation but from other
violations too so by simplifying the
statute to just require that a violation
has occurred in order for Dees to be
able to enforce we go a long way to
protecting the water quality of our
lakes and rivers um it's I I kind of um
compare it to any one of us I won't
mention anyone in particular but any one
of us who may get stopped for driving
over the speed
limit um we don't we can't just say to
the officer I didn't know what the speed
limit was I didn't look at the sign or
I'm unaware of any damage or risk that
speeding might occur we just get a
notice of violation and we have the
consequences of that action well we
should apply that same level of of
action and enforcement to the protection
of our waterways as well as our roadways
so I would be happy to entertain any
questions you
have
any questions by represent
representative yes okay thank you uh for
taking my question um now would this be
a person cuts the trees for example
would they get the violation then right
away they would be noticed for
committing the violation but under
current statute the dees still has
leeway on what they can do um you know
maybe they might take that violation as
an opportunity to educate the Violator
um but it could be that they may assess
the damage and that's been caused and
and initi and issue a violation that may
be heard in Superior Court with a fine
or something like
that for a followup yes uh but how does
that fit in with this I don't quite
understand well so for this
representative gold is that for Dees to
enforce the shoreline protection act
they not only have to show that a
violation has occurred because that's
pretty straightforward but they also
have to show that that violation damaged
the Waterway if you if you look on line
three of the bill it says in damaging
the public
Waterway and they continue to violate it
and that's where it gets really
murky um sorry for the pun
but anyone question by anyone else on
the board on the
committee um thank you Mr chair I just
want to find out if somebody's from Dees
is going to be testifying following you
yeah I do believe we have here and
we speaker right after and uh represent
I think we also um received a letter
from Dees in support of the bill and um
Mr chair as I spoke to you earlier um I
do want to read um some test testimony
that was sent to representative McDonald
in wolfboro he asked if I could read it
into the record it's from um Linda
Murray who is a selectman in wolfboro
and she writes as one selectman and a
member of the wolfboro waters committee
I am in support of HB 1103 the shoreline
protection act enforcement this
legislation will Aid towns in making it
clear that the shorland protection act
can be enforced with a consequence
having legislation to protect the Lakes
will be a plus for all citizens of the
State of New Hampshire since the State
lakes are key assets that help Drive the
state's
economy representative G for another
question yes thank you uh I noticed in
reading this it's
uh on the last page of this paper that
we have of the bill it says uh or a
scope of violations that may be
committed by
municipalities so uh and then
municipalities is in the next line also
so is this different from a ordinary
citizen cutting down trees for example
I'm sorry representative are you on the
financial yeah the very yeah at the very
the very last page
yeah oh
I DS could probably comment more on this
but there are several municipalities who
have adopted the shoreline protection
act is part of their ordinance so they
have the power to enforce that ordinance
and and they couldn't they could do it
just on a violation without having to
demonstrate direct damage and then they
would then collect the fines
themselves is there anyone else on the
on the committee who has a a question if
not okay thank you very
much
and I'll next call Darlene for from
representing the Hampshire Department of
Environmental
Services good afternoon my name is
Darlene Forest I'm the Wetland Bureau
administrator at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services we
have already circulated our we have both
emailed and circulated hard copies of
our written testimony the Department of
Environmental Services does support this
bill I'm not going to bother to read
this letter as we've already provided it
to
you so to build upon the comments that
were already offered or the testimony
that was already offered the shorland
protection act in the way the department
chooses to enforce the Shoreland
protection act our charge is
Environmental Quality so our first
priority anytime we have an
environmental violation regardless of
program is to attempt to have
environmental corrective measures
whether it's the replanting of trees the
treatment of storm water remediation is
our first goal however there are times
when damage is
irreparable or where an individual
simply does not want to participate in
that restoration or remediation process
or whatever reason that may be without
the ability to impose a fine we don't
have any
other method of encouraging someone to
work with us and where something is
irreparable then there is no penalty and
the truth of the matter is there are
times when someone comes in and
absolutely devastates a site that will
take a century or so to repair if you
cut
down you know 7500 year old trees you
cannot bring those in in the back of a
of a truck they you do not ever recreate
what you've
lost so there has to be some ability for
us to exert some kind of Leverage it is
not our first
choice when in 2008 when the Act was
redrafted the language that we have here
is essentially that first line it is
very similar to every other compliance
line that we have in every other statute
when someone violates the law we have
the option of imposing a financial
penalty for that
violation it used to say it was an
additional violation for each additional
day we are not asking you we are not
encouraging that at this time at this
time we would be happy just to be able
to find when this language was changed
in 2010 2011 the two caveats that we've
asked to remove those were added and
those two caveats the first is for us to
impose a violation we need to show that
that particular violation on that
particular lot degraded the water for
the entire protected water body so if
you can imagine on Lake wiip pasak
what you would need to do on a singular
lot to show that that singular lot
degraded the water quality of all of
winaki that is an impossible task the
second part of this
is if there is a failure to make a good
faith effort by The Violator to
remediate good faith effort that's an
indication that we have to prove state
of mind um in order for us to say you
didn't do this in good faith you have to
have a significant level of evidence
that despite what the person put forward
either they didn't intend to do it or
they know perfectly well it won't
succeed or that it won't make up for
what was lost to give you an example of
uh how this might work or what we've
encountered in the past our first this
coming to our awareness how difficult
this became we had an individual who was
a developer who was on their third
violation on
winaki you would think by the third
violation
for elimination of the Waterfront buffer
that that would be an easy find we we
could not find because after clearing
the Waterfront buffer they came back and
offered to plant single digits of
blueberry bushes that was considered by
the attorneys as a good faith for
mediation effort and thus despite having
a a prior history and despite someone
who as a commercial Enterprise Who
develops properties and an expectation
that they should have known the law
simply offering a few replanting having
removed the ground cover and the
trees eliminated our ability to actually
impose any other penalties and if we
have no ability to impose any other
Financial penalties then he has no
reason to actually make an honest
attempt to replant that
buffer and along those lines the way
that we often would use a fine is we can
propose a fine and hold it in a bance
until such time as restoration is
complete again this isn't like we're
looking and and our fines don't go into
our budget we do not use fines because
we want to take in income or because we
just like finding people for us a f is a
tool to encourage restoration good
actual meaningful
restoration um if you have any questions
I would be happy to answer
those questions by members of the
committee representative
clerk thank you m thank you Mr chair I
just uh was wondering uh Miss Forest if
you could give us maybe one or two more
examples of this if you have them the
more the better just to to illustrate uh
the problems that that you've
encountered with the the vagueness of
the law that would be helpful thank
you we have a couple that are Active
cases that I will refrain from
using um if I may I would be happy to
actually provide photographs I can go
back to the office in a certain number
of days I can provide the committee with
photographs and examples of areas where
we would have liked to have find someone
but the option was not
available thank
you that answer your
question represent representative LoveIt
for a question how how thank you for
taking my question how how many feet
from the shoreline would this act
pertain to 50 how about a
river or protected Waters which would be
lakes and ponds greater than 10 acres in
size tidal waters rivers that are either
designated under the designated Rivers
program or we use the fourth order of
the staer method so it's main stem
streams not your
Headwaters for those water bodies that
are protected that's our jurisdictional
areas it is areas Within 250t F feet so
if you violate one of the minimum
standards of the Shoreland protection
act within 250 fet that goes to storm
water
treatment whether or not you have a
permit buffer criterias we only maintain
vegetated buffers by law within 150 ft
so that is further reduced use of
herbicides or pesticides without proper
licensing imp permits within 50
ft improper sighting of septic systems
are SE IC Systems without permits we
could also um we would normally defer
the subsurface but that is something we
could also do as well as failure to
maintain citation erosion controls
leading
to um things of that nature so those are
the specific
activities 150 ft of protected
jurisdictional waters for vegetation
maintenance 250 ft for overall
structural sighting storm water and
failure to maintain erosion
controls
representative har for a question thank
you for taking my
question I'm having a hard time
following the actual bill and how it
impacts you um the bill I'm looking at
only Strikes Out basically notification
to the person that created this damage
and asked them to remediate so is the
notification provision which is holding
you back so you don't want to
notify um no it is the the first phrase
and damaging the public Waterway so they
actually have to damage the public
waterway that is what I mentioned about
we must prove that that particular
violation on that particular site had a
measurable impact damaging impact on the
Waterway who then after notification by
the department fails to make a good
faith effort so the first part of this
is the damaging the public Waterway
proof of damage of the public Waterway
the second is once we've notified them
did they or did they not make a
goodfaith effort so how do we prove that
the effort that they made was in good
faith or not which is proving state of
mind we followup so if we take this out
and you have other Provisions in your
letter it says you have other Provisions
to enforce it would the violators still
get a notice from
you oh we'll still notify yes we have to
contact the vi or first thing we're
going to contact the Violator of is we
have evidence that a violation may have
occurred that we are going to
investigate we will then notify them of
our findings with a request for
corrective actions we don't normally ask
for a fine until we've exhausted those
other options which means we've had
consistent back and forth communication
Beyond just a simple
notification okay thank
you representative har
thank you chair um one other question if
you may uh um so in the case where uh
you were just mentioning spray of
pesticides is that how does that work
how do you find for damages you go and
you uh suspect somebody of spraying and
then you test the water um have you been
able to Pro not prosecute someone for
that sure so I mentioned pesticides
because it is actually one of the things
that's very specifically listed in the
law but I can tell you that I've been
working in Shoreland since 1998 and we
have never successfully pursued a
chemical pesticide or fertilizer
violation um and the reason for that is
because of the level of evidence
required you have to catch them in the
ACT that's what I so yes you absolutely
have to catch them in the act and I I
would say this if the day we actually
catch a pesticide or chemical fertilizer
professional in the act
if and there are Provisions that they
can do so with a permit but if we catch
them violating as a
professional that's irreparable you
can't take those chemicals back once
you've applied them that's a provision
we would probably lean heavily
on representative Derby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um you said that you could provide some
photos or some examples for
representative Harvey buia I was
wondering if you is with those examples
you could um provide examples of where
you've been able to negotiate with the
people with the property owners um and
you haven't they've been by what I'm
trying to say
is you've found that there's been a
violation and they've been willing to
work with you and it wouldn't have
resulted in a
find oh those are the easy ones okay
yeah yes thank
you we can we can we can provide you
with a few examples of various
outcomes
yes representative veale for a for a
question thank you Mr chair um thank you
for taking my question um I just wanted
to go over what says the assumes that
since the Department's already required
to investigate this is in the I'm sorry
at the bottom of the fiscal
note such violations pursuant to RSA 43-
B
co5 one I would there would there for be
no significant additional
workload so this won't cause more of a
workload no we already have a violation
we're already pursuing it in attempting
to get rediation so this is this would
not actually increase our workload
whatsoever thank you for taking my
question anyone
else
ltina ltin for question
um
me um I'm wondering about what the scale
of the fines are and say you were to
find someone
for clear cutting the land right down to
the Waterfront is it enough of a
deterrent for them not to just consider
that an expense they're willing to
overlook when they're perhaps developing
a million doll property
um well speaking of the fact that it's
hard for us to prove state of mind it's
always hard for us to determine just
what is a deterrent for one individual
compared to another
um simply removing this
provision a single violation so if they
only cut the Waterfront buffer that is a
single violation of the ACT if they
violated multiple Provisions it's $5,000
per provision violated because it's not
a day on it's not a day over day any
longer so there
are there are approximately
eight minimum standards that are in the
law if someone managed to violate all
eight of them at the same time that
would be
ambitious you would have potential for
40,000 total and
penalties
if you're a small homeowner on a small
pond or on a river that very much
hurts um if you're paying two million
bucks to buy a piece of property so that
you can tear down the residence that's
on it and build a new
one that might not cover
your your yeah it might not be a big
deal but it that totally depends on the
circumstances of the individ idual
involved
um perhaps that's a conversation for a
different
day thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um would
this speed up the
remediation I'm talking about specific
examples where you people have not been
able
to get action we believe that this would
speed up remediation because we could in
fact state
that if you do not work with us on
compliance and we cannot reach an
an acceptable outcome we will begin
imposing fines uh it it gives us
leverage um again it's a stick we'd
rather not use but unfortunately
sometimes it is rather
helpful thank you Jer has a question uh
is I mean it looks like
you're this looks like uh you're we're
changing the law to really a strict
liability uh you did it you're in other
words You' you've done the deed and so
you're guilty because you did you did
the deed
not because not because of
your uh your mental state or because of
your
intent uh is that what you what that is
that what you're focusing on to use the
representative representative
rong's prior analogy if you were
speeding because you were doing 50 and a
35 but you didn't realize the speed
limit was
35 it's the same same idea so yet the
answer is yes however again our intent
is not so much that we want to use this
all of the time but we don't want we'd
like to have it in our tool box we're
not asking that they're mandatory F but
we are asking for having this tool back
in our toolbox if in fact someone comes
to us and says I had no idea and they're
making they are trying to remediate and
they put it they do everything they can
to restore the situation to an
environmentally stable situation that
will
recover that's what's most important to
us so from a strict liability yes if you
did it it's your property or you did it
and you were hired to do it and you you
still did it either one of those
situations if you committed the ACT you
are a potential candidate to receive a
fine a financial
penalty but uh we're not asking for
language where it's mandatory we're
asking again just to have the tool
available
okay anyone
else seeing no one else thank you very
much I will be here throughout if
anybody has a
question
okay chair recognizes uh Sarah
Holland in opposition to the bill
representing the New Hampshire Realtors
good afternoon thank you for giving me
the opportunity my name is Sarah Holland
I'm a real estate agent and I'm also the
vice chair of the public policy
Committee of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors and I'm here
representing the Realtors as we have
concerns with this bill um Realtors know
that obviously properties on clean and
well-managed lakes and rivers are more
attractive to buyers and Property Owners
by protecting views recreational
opportunities and overall quality of
life
however removing this these items at the
beginning of this I feel do not achieve
what Dees is looking for and as
representative harb had mentioned um the
notification piece is important um the
sherland um protection act plays a very
important role in advancing the goals of
Dees however the bill appears to remove
the option for them to notify the
property owners as they in viation of
the statute and give them the
opportunity to correct um although
stated by the sponsors um we find it
unclear that Dees retains the right to
educate and provide a warning because
not all um violations of the Shoreland
protection act are willful um Property
Owners simply make mistakes or are
ignorant um of some parts of the act and
as we know the act itself does change
over time so keeping up with that um can
be um may not be top of mind for a
number of property owners especially new
waterfront property owners and as stated
before Shoreland protection extends 250
ft um so that is a decent distance from
the Waterfront so folks may not even
realize they fall under that protection
act so we Rec recognize that some
Property Owners May willfully violate
provisions of the Shoreland act I was
actually on a tour with Dees on Lake
Winn basaki and saw some of those um
violations
um but Dees may feel that a fine must be
imposed and we agree that that's the
case um however notification to span
every single violation is important
um relative to the removal the language
of the bill there are three parts that
are really being removed the first first
is the damage to Waterway threshold the
second is notification and then the
third is good faith effort um it seems
the removal of the damag threshold will
accomplish what Dees is looking for so
we ask that um there be revisions
made to retain the notification piece
and I'm happy to take any
questions represent representative Derby
The Call by representative wolf thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question are you familiar with
subsection B of the pro of the law you
of the bill that's being change you
notice of course that at line five ends
with a colon because there's three
subsections below that and those three
subsections haven't changed subsection B
says the commiss commissioner after
notice and hearing pursuant to RSA 541a
May impose an administrative fine so I
just want wondering if you had
considered the both both the fact that
um after notice in hearing which is
required and the May if that you you
still believe that the commissioner has
to impose the fine and that notification
isn't required thank you yeah thank you
um I don't have that in front of me at
the moment um but to our um stakeholders
that it was unclear to them at the
reading of this that they Dees retained
um that in any other way yeah
representative
wolf do you believe that there's any
obligation on the part of the Realtors
to apprise purchasers of the Shoreland
protection
act yeah so we do um provide
notification obviously every um there
are many practitioners that are not
Realtors so I can only speak for my own
um my own Professional Organization um
however there are a lot of properties
that don't train change ownership so
there's not an opportunity for this
education to occur for a number of
properties throughout the
state any other questions by members of
the of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much Glen
Rogers friends of hot hole
pond
thank you folks for letting me say just
a a few words um uh at HOV Han we we
applied uh to uh build an addition uh to
our house we went through the whole
process of making out the extensive um
uh Shoreline protection act requirements
and we uh we promised to do do certain
things to uh toh put in vegetative
buffers and uh do storm water mitigation
and so forth and I always assumed that
if we didn't do that that there would be
a penalty uh and that seems to be that
seems to be a reasonable thing whether
or not there was long-term damage to the
water body uh or not if if you signed
and said you would do certain things
then there should be a penalty because
you didn't do them uh and that's that's
essentially uh uh what I what I wanted
to say and it turned out that uh we uh
did not do the property addition so we
we never had to to to worry about that
but it seems straightforward that if you
said you were going to do
something then you should do it and
there should be a penalty if you didn't
do
it be glad to take any
questions
representative
lante thank you uh so when you said you
filled out the paperwork was that for
your building permit application yes yes
it was with the town well we were told
by the town that the first thing we had
to do was to make out this entire
application from the shorland protection
act um and then in the end and we got
permission we um and then we went
through uh the time of Lowden and we and
we were
denied um had Fairly complicated set of
circumstances but we were denied so we
we didn't we didn't do the building um
but it seems to me I had promised to do
certain things we had promised to do
certain things if we didn't do it there
should be there should be a
penalty okay thank
you anyone
else
question seeing no one else thank you
very much
you uh Pat
tarpy Uh representing the Lake wiip
pasak
Association thank you for giving me this
opportunity to speak um I'm Pat tarpy
I'm president of the Lake wabaki
Association we are a 501c3 nonprofit
whose mission is dedicated to protecting
the water quality and natural resources
of the lake and the Watershed so we work
with the eight shorefront towns as well
as there's a total of 14 municipalities
within that
Watershed
um i' I'd like to point out I guess a
few bullets and um first of all the the
whole purpose of the RSA
483 is that the state recognizes is that
the
shorefront are are valuable and fragile
natural resources and our public waters
are held in the trust of the
state our organization cannot enforce
any rules the municipalities tend to
look to the state when it's in that 250
ft Shoreland Zone even if the local
municipalities can adopt
stricter I work with a lot of them and
there's different mentalities within
each town around Lake
winaki um some are more proactive but
others do say the state says this that's
what we're going to go by or it's a
public water it's the state's
responsibility to enforce this act it's
not ours Code Enforcement Officers we
have found are very reluctant and they
are overburdened with other areas that
they are
following that's one of my point our
organization receives complaints every
year here about violations of this act
and they are frustrated they're
frustrated with Dees and that's not
always fair to DS I think because their
hands tend to be tied at times as
Darlene has just been
indicating um I also sat on the state's
cyanobacteria planning advisory
committee they released their plan in
November of last year this was one of
their recommendations by the advisory
committee member
um to have strict stronger enforcement
and penalty structure Dees is not asking
for a stronger penalty structure they're
just asking to remove being able to
prove that the water quality impact has
occurred um I submitted online testimony
and in that you'll see I did submit
photos of one particular egregious
property on lake
winaki and my fourth point is the
Shoreland represents to me the first and
last line of defense for pollution from
entering our water bodies and I would
Advocate that shorefront property owners
actually have a greater responsibility
to know what the law is because anything
they do directly impacts that lake or
Pond um ignorance of the law I don't
think is a very
good
excuse probably personally um also once
the violation has occurred the damage is
done the trees are cut the foundations
poured the shorelines
destroyed we have conducted watershed
management studies on Lake quak for
several of the bay areas and I can tell
you from the nutrient modeling that we
have done there's a lag time and impact
and it can take up to 10 years before
you're going to see the impacts to the
lake from what was done from development
10 years prior so I would urge the
committee to support this bill and pass
it and I'll take any
questions any question representative
Derby then representative hary bull
thank you um chair um thank you for
taking my
question um like you mentioned Shoreline
or um waterfront property owners bear a
burden of responsibility to understand
the the rules of of their Lake of their
you know their part property I'm
wondering most of these lakes and I have
to imagine your organization has a
Property Owners Association or maybe
multiple property owners associations do
you know if if they try to get out the
word to Property Owners to make them
aware of of sort of good Property
Maintenance practices and also sort of
uh U concerns with violating this this
act thank
you um there are m multiple homeowner
associations or Road associations on
Winn pasak um they hold annual meetings
in the summer I would say Pro I'm going
to say most of them do try and share
this information we have an email list
where we send out notifications of
services we offer what we're doing um we
work with we partner with New Hampshire
Lakes on providing what's called be wiy
blue at link smart which is a program
for residential property owners where
we'll go out and voluntarily walk their
property with them and give them
recommendations on making
improvements uh a lot of these homeowner
associations or smaller Lake
Associations are aware of that
program um but there are times when I've
tried to go speak to a small Homeowner
Association and they like we're not
interested in
hearing certain aspects so
I can't speak for all of them I would
say the majority do try and get the word
out all right representative Harvey bul
for a question thank you uh Mr chair and
thank you uh for your testimony can you
um you spoke about the violation the
complaints that you've received can you
give me some of the most
common uh some examples of the most
common violations that are that people
are repor in or that that you know about
that are happening
thanks I would say tree cutting is the
most common complaint I get whether it's
clear cutting or even taking down
individual
trees um erosion issues coming into the
lake lack of proper barriers to prevent
that um those are the most common that
that I
receive any other questions by members
of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much final card I have is Andrea Laro of
New Hampshire
Lakes good afternoon members of the
committee I'm Andrea Laro the president
of New Hampshire lakes and I thank you
for this opportunity to just say a few
brief words um in support of this bill
New Hampshire Lakes we're a Statewide
nonprofit organization we represent
about
275 Lake
Associations and a couple of thousand uh
Lake
enthusiasts and we support this bill for
all of the reasons that representative
rang Dees um and Lake wnab basaki
Association have uh already explain to
you and I just thought I would add that
we've heard a lot of talk about wiip
pasak Rock and some of the unfortunate
egregious violations um on the big lake
and again we represent 275 Lake
Associations and this is a Statewide
problem uh I would say for the most part
um you know folks don't mean to violate
the ACT um but there are some folks out
there that um maybe they decide that
it's you know it doesn't have much teeth
you know they're going to risk it and
and do this project um because they're
not going to get you know snagged for it
um we hear often from our Lake
Association members um that this is very
frustrating that you know they Lake
Associations throughout the state these
are volunteers that are donating their
time um and their resources their their
their their money to uh do projects and
do education to uh help protect um the
lakes of New Hampshire for all of us and
it's there's nothing more you know
disincentivizing are frustrating for
them when you know they are spending all
this time and energy and sweat acurity
to protect the state resource and then
someone you know someone um that thinks
differently goes ahead and removes all
the trees on their property or you does
some other IR reparable egregious
violation and and it really becomes a
sour spot for all these good people that
are trying to protect our our Lakes so
to have the ability uh for Dees to um
hold those people accountable who um you
know won't work with them to fix the
problem um I think is a step in the
right direction to help protect uh the
fragile health of our lakes and I would
be happy to answer any
questions any questions by members of
the
committee seeing seeing none thank you
very much thank
you that's the last uh pink card I have
is there anyone uh was to wish wishes to
testify or or correct the the record
anything like that if not seeing none I
call the hearing
closed and we have the next hearing is
starts in 11
minutes
e
like to call the meeting to
order all the hearing to House
Bill
1113 relative to Shoreland septic
systems
[Music]
and representative run the floor is
yours thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh the committee for giving me this
opportunity to discuss with you HB
1113 um I've gotten some written remarks
down so if you don't mind I'm going to
just kind of read from them since I
joined this committee back in 2019 we
have seen septic system bills come
before us multiple times there is a
reason for this
septic systems in Failure not only cause
untreated sewage to be released to the
ground surface Andor to back up into
pipes but failed septic systems near a
water shoreline cause a runoff of sewage
into that water this runoff can has
contributed to increased nutrients that
with increasing warming water
temperatures trigger cyanobacteria
blooms toxic cyanobacteria blooms create
a serious health r risk to our lakes and
rivers and for any person or pet
recreating in them so the impact of
failed systems goes far beyond the
property owner and their property it
becomes a public threat as you'll hear
from Dees failed septic systems can
account for up to 22% of the phosphorus
loading of lakes if we can make Headway
into reducing this load it will help
address the rise in cyanobacteria blooms
New Hampshire lakes and rivers are
experiencing this build does not go
after every Waterfront septic system
it's only impacting properties within
the sensitive Shoreline Zone that are
being sold to ensure their failed septic
systems do not get passed down to the
new owner to continue the sewage runoff
HB 1113 requires developed Waterfront
which is already defined in statute and
new in this bill to be within 250 ft of
the waters reference line to have their
septic systems evaluated only if it was
never approved by Dees to begin with OR
that approval is older than 20 years if
it is determined to be in Failure the
sale is contingent on its
replacement now I realize opponents to
this bill will claim that it is unfair
to people who must sell their property
within a reasonable time frame as
replacing a system can take several
months I see their point and I'm willing
to draft an amendment to require the
buyer a fair time frame to replace the
septic system with subsequent
notification to
Dees I also understand that some buyers
want the property so they can demolish
the existing structure and rebuild a new
one which would require a new septic
system design anyway I am open to that
Amendment as well well but I am not open
and neither should we or any granite
Staters to allowing a failed septic
system to continue to pollute our public
Waters without any plan for
resolution HB 11113 needs to be a bill
this re this committee recommends for
passage as possibly amended and I I
probably would um want to suggest to the
chair that we have a work session on
this or I can work on amendments with
anybody who's willing willing to help to
account for some of those situations
where um replacing the septic system by
closing is presents undue hardship to
the buyer or to the seller so with that
I'd be happy to address any questions
you
have any questions by members of the
committee representative
lontine hello do you know if um they
choose to remodel or ADD an addition to
the old house as opposed to just
demolishing it do they also have to get
a new septic permit or I'm not exactly
sure but um I know the person here from
DS makes their living understanding
septic system so I'm going to defer to
to Mr troid to answer
that any other questions from members of
the
committee representative harb then
representative wolf thank you
representative for taking my question do
you have any opinion at this time about
the time to um remedy and rectify the
problem with the septic system and part
two of that is in mass under Title Five
they give the owner a year to remedy did
you have any idea is that sufficient or
would you agree to a year in an
amendment um I I would be open anything
I just think it's really important that
we put an end date on a failed septic
system and just say you know by this
date you have to have it replaced or you
have to vacate the property I mean I can
understand if someone's buying an Old
Camp and they have plans to demolish it
and and build a year round home that it
may take them more than a year but after
maybe a year they would either have to
have um a septic system replaced or in
process or um or they'd have to vacate
the property but we just can't allow
that continued SE AG to to go into our
Lakes um I'm I'm happy to work with
anyone on this I just I think we need to
make progress as I've said and and and
you've seen this representative heart
we've just seen these bills come and
come and come and we've made no progress
on it and when I look at watershed
management plans that have been
submitted to Dees and see that up to 22%
of that loading is from failed septic
systems you know we have to we have to
start somewhere and I thought starting
with homes that are transferring
ownership is is probably a good place to
start because it does give that
government or regulator regulatory um
involvement engagement in that process
to ensure that it can
occur representative wolf for a question
Then followed by representative Darby
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question this only pertains to
houses that are in the process of being
sold correct are you aware of towns that
are now putting in regular requirements
for annual um Tri anual inspections no
I'm not I think that's a wonderful idea
representative wolf um no this is I just
think I wanted to come up with some
minimal solution to start working on the
problem some some something to make some
progress I do understand that there are
some communities that have strict septic
ordinances and they're very engaged with
inspections and and I think what we
heard from um Miss tarpy from Lake
winaki Association though that there
there those type of municipalities run
the gamut there could be some that
really aren't engaged they just don't
have the time for a health officer to be
involved in in a septic system issue and
and there's some that that do but as was
also stated these are are are Waters
held in the public public trust and I
think we need to start making progress
on protecting those
waters for a followup just a quick
followup there is one of the four towns
in the sopy Watershed has it in law now
and there are two others that are
bringing up the town meeting good I'd
like to look at those I'll check them
out thank you representative Derby for a
question thank you Mr chair thank thank
you representative rang for taking my
question um this is sort of related um
to what representative wolf said um
section two of this bill um it seems to
be slightly different um but I but maybe
it's not maybe I'm just misreading it
it's about um it's basically I think
about letting local municipalities um
provide U more strict requirements I'm
just hoping to get your perspective on
what section two was intended to do um
thank you very much for the question um
I'm going to actually um ask if you
could ask um Mr trobridge that question
um I I actually work with Dees on this
bill um I mean I I think we still have
some some amending to do to make it
really um address the the concerns that
are out there but um I do know that
Municipal municipalities that have
stricter rules those those hold those
would have to be followed first before
state regulation
would any questions by any other members
of the committee
seea there thank you Mr chair I'm
looking at um oh hopefully I can gather
my thoughts
here the 250 ft of reference line that's
on line five on the first page of the
bill um do you know why that was changed
from 200 fet of reference line I believe
200 feet existed in an earlier bill um
by representative Spang and and I'm I'm
hoping that Mr troit could provide
Clarity for that but I believe the
regulation was changed to 250 so this
reflects the new
regulation thank you so
much any other questions by members of
the
committee see none very much
Jer C calls Philip throwbridge
representing New Hampshire
Dees oh there's two of
you same oh the same name too but
damn right good afternoon chairman Rulo
members of the committee for the record
my name is Philip Trowbridge I'm the
manager of the land resources management
program at Dees which includes the
subsystem subsurface systems Bureau
which regulates septic systems and
joining me today is Scott Hazelton who's
the new administrator of the subservice
systems
Bureau uh can I ask uh Mr hegels toh
fill out a card after after after it's
over after you finish their supply
absolutely uh so I'd like to start with
a little bit of background if I could uh
and then I've been trying to jot on the
questions that have come along um uh RSA
45 a39 requires a site assessment be
done as a part of a real estate
transaction for waterfront properties um
some things about that the Waterfront
site assessment is done by a permitted
septic system
designer uh what it tells you is it
tells you how much Wastewater uh the lot
can handle for
treatment um it's uh it's based on the
soils of the lot the size of the lot lot
whether there's Wetlands on the property
whether there's ledge as I like to say
geology is Destiny when it comes to how
much water waste water can be treated by
a
lot uh the reason this was done and why
it's important is that um a lot of
people buying properties are looking to
expand them and they may be buying a
small camp but they eventually want to
build a four-bedroom house and they need
to know the time of sale whether the lot
can handle that Wastewater um there's
also cases where there's been after the
fact um or there's been an illegal
expansion of a property someone's buying
a four-bedroom house they think it's the
septic system when lot can handle a
4bedroom house and they are unpleasantly
surprised that it cannot uh so that's uh
what the Waterfront site assessment does
uh what it doesn't do is it doesn't
evaluate the condition of the septic
system on the
property uh which is been part of a
weakness uh of the bill um or of the
statute
HB 1113 would add this detailed
evaluation of the existing septic system
you know for properties where the septic
system either does not have a state
approval uh or that state approval is
more than 20 years old so it's taking a
sort of segment of the properties uh and
saying that someone should really take a
look at the specific on the sub system
in the
ground um it also adds a requirement
that the failed system uh be replaced
before the sale can go through
the department feels that some sort of
Waterfront site assessment is important
um a couple of reasons uh water quality
in New Hampshire's Lakes is
declining harmful algal blooms are more
frequent uh in this last year in 2023 47
of our Lakes had cyanobacteria
advisories
issued failing septic systems is a
significant contributor of the nutrients
that uh fuel these algae blooms
uh and detecting and fixing
malfunctioning subject systems is a way
to immediately um take take action to
reduce these nutrient loads and improve
the water
quality what we feel are important
elements of a waterfront site assessment
are there's really three of them um the
buyers know what they're buying at the
time of the transaction so that they can
there can be proper negotiations between
the buyer and the
seller ensuring that these waterfront
properties have a state approved septic
system that's been designed to
adequately treat the waste uh there are
plenty of camps out there that were are
55 gallon drums that are called a septic
system uh and that third a professional
looks at the system to determine if it's
in Failure uh at the time of the sale uh
so that we can make sure that it's
working
properly HB 1113 achieves these obes
jectives uh but as representative rang
alluded there may be some disagreement
on the approach taken by this bill
therefore the de is neutral on this bill
however we do think that the the
principles behind it are sound and there
are ways to achieve these objectives
that would have broad
support thank you and I'm um willing to
take your questions
please any questions by members of the
committee
represent
oh representative D um thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
can um can you describe what a um I
think you did but what a uh detailed sub
Disposal system evaluation consists of
um uh how much approximately how much it
might cost as opposed to a site survey
um and for um failed system
um that are detected other than the um
other than you know the cyanobacteria
concerns we've heard because of
phosphorus what other kinds of water
quality problems could be
introduced okay um so by detailed
evaluation um what we what we expect is
that someone investigates the system on
the ground um and normally that involves
someone you know finding the septic tank
opening that to see if it's
cracked um reviewing the area of the
leech field for any signs of breakout
and as a designer we would be looking
for someone to understand the depth to
the water table in the vicinity of the
septic system to know whether the system
is in uh located in the the water
table um I I can't tell you how many
times I've spoken to someone who said
I've got the best septic system in the
the world it just works forever it's
been in here for 50 years and it never
fails and that's because it's basically
in the
groundwater um so there's a there's
something that's beneath the surface
that needs to be
evaluated in terms of the cost I really
don't feel that I can say that right now
because I'm not a permanent designer
this would be something that they would
have to determine um uh but it's it
would you know uh I'd say it's you know
on par with what their the charge is now
for the Waterfront site
assessment um and I think your third
question was what other water quality
impacts would be associated with the
failing septic system and the most uh
obvious one is BAC ecoli bacteria and
pathogens um in the waters that where
people
swim representative tell
it thank you for your testimony and
thank you for taking my question thank
you Mr chair for let me ask one um so I
I guess I don't know how familiar you
are with the current situation in Berlin
that's where I'm from um I know a little
I've been exposed to a little bit about
feal matter bubbling through the ground
in the last couple weeks on a river into
a
river um so I guess my my question is
you know what are the signs of a of a
leaking septic system look like on a
shorel
uh
versus you know on a you know property
not near the Shoreland um you know I
took us I don't this whole entire City's
system was leaking into the river for
several days a week before anyone was
able to recognize that I'm sure that a
residential property where the uh
production is much
smaller um might take more time
um thank you for the question I will
start with the response and then I'm
going to turn this over to Scott um who
has more experience in this area um
there there's I think what you've
experienced at a larger scale is is you
know the same as what would be happening
at a smaller scale it's just you know
the sizes are different uh but the the
obvious things that people look for are
signs of breakout which is wetness odor
is a very obvious thing um and um
the um and sometimes there's backup into
the the house um like I said one of the
things that's harder to detect is when
the septic system is in the groundwater
because then all of this is happening um
out of sight and often out of mind and
by the time it reaches the water body
which is I think the case you you're
dealing with um it's in the water it's a
little bit less you know it's harder to
see um that's why it's important to know
uh where the the elevation of the septic
system relative to this to the water
table in that area and that's what a
permited designer can
do Scott would you like to add anything
no I think you've covered the majority
of it I think that uh one of the hardest
things to do is to determine whether or
not um a system is has been installed in
that seasonal high water table and then
as you alluded to that seeing this in a
water body is also another difficult uh
thing some of the other things you may
see from a failed system are evidence of
Cloudy slimy water surfacing somewhere
along that effent disposal area and then
flowing across the surface of the ground
into the water table and those are those
those can be tested um but short of
determining whether or not a system is
in the seasonal High groundwater table
and then testing uh the the lakefront
water for the presence of of
contaminants caused by affluent um it's
it's
difficult
just a quick followup so I guess in our
case it was pretty easy to point to the
city and say we know where it's coming
from um is it it generally difficult to
treat to like is if you have several
Property Owners is it pretty easy to
track down which one's the the offending
tank or is it is it uh you know does it
in these type of Investigations or is it
pretty
quick yeah thank you for the question I
think in all cases the the level of the
level of the of the problem is makes it
easier to determine um and there are
methods for you know doing bracketed
testing so you um especially on a river
where you can work your way upstream and
you know determine where the V where the
ecoi starts to be showing up you know
obviously um properties Upstream uh
Downstream of that would not be the
issue and so it's not that difficult but
it does involve doing some uh water
quality
testing
no one there's no one
else just Ballpark and time frame like
like what weeks or days or months or
like how long does that investigation
usually uh you know it's a uh the um for
ecoi bacteria it has to be tested very
quickly so you get a quick turnaround
from the laboratory so it's it's kind of
Manpower dependent uh as soon as you can
get people out to do the testing and and
look at the property um it's not um you
know it's more about you having someone
be able to go out and collect the sample
and get them to the lab then a long
analysis
time thank you representative Veil then
representative Don thank you Mr chair um
thank you for taking my question rang
said that she would consider amending
the bill to give the new owner six
months to replace the septic system as
long as they confirm with d Dees that
the repair was made can Dees handle this
extra administ rative
task is that an issue yeah yes thank you
for that question um we
um the we expect that this would not be
an ex a significant extra administrative
burden on the department um and so that
if there were uh you when we we get
notification of failed subject systems
now we have um followup related to those
uh this would add to that but not in a
way that I think would require and
additional
Staffing thank you you answered my
followup thank you Mr chair thank you
for my question H it's actually going to
follow on to representative fails I was
going to ask roughly what's the
percentage of of failed septic systems
you think that the state has already um
out there so I'm from Salem so we all
know about Arlington Pond and I'm
curious how many homeowners that this
would actually affect across the state
um that they would need to start to look
at this
cost it's a thank you for the very
excellent question um one of my
questions I've been asking since I
started this job was just some basic
intelligence regarding septic systems in
the state we have all kinds of
information about the wastewater
treatment plants for that serve our
municip our cities um but yet more than
half of the state you know septic
systems is their form of Wastewater
treatment uh but yet our our the
information we have is related to the
systems that we have permitted since
1967 some of which have been replaced
multiple times since then so you can't
even just look at the number of permits
we've issued to know even how many
septic systems there are and or either
age um so this is kind of what I've been
interested in is what um you know how
many very very old systems at risk of
failure are there out there and we
really don't have an answer to that
question so it's a great question I'm
sorry I don't have it um I will say that
the vast majority of our work is spent
permitting new systems or replacement
systems and that we deal with you know
um in the order of 50 failed systems per
year um however I should say that a lot
of those failed systems are dealt with
at the municipal level by the health
officers they they have the most uh uh
far-reaching authority to deal with fail
septic systems and we encourage them to
to take that action themselves so we
don't aren't notified of all of
them anyone else from the
committee representative
har um thank you very much for your
testimony um is that 50 failed Shoreline
septic systems
correct no thank you for the question
the clarification no it's 50 total 50
total in the state yeah that that we are
involved with that you were involved
thank you very
much representative Derby thank you Mr
chair um the section four of this bill
sort of clarifies existing language
about notifying Dees um about a failed
uh failed septic system um which makes
sense but my real question is the
existing you know law that says um that
the designer has to notify Dees um of
the failures what do you do with that
information if you if you learn of a
failure um Scott would you like to
handle this one sure um so most of the
times that we hear of these failures are
from the health officers um once a
failed system has been identified it's
up to the health officer to work with
that the owner of that structure
residential structure building to either
pump their tank um and stay in the house
or if it's it's an egregious violation
to vacate the structure um at which
point a licensed designer will get
involved and and design a new system a
replac replacement system for them um
there's a process that goes along with
that but there's time frames associated
with that process and typically it's a
30-day design and review process and
then they're given 90 days to replace it
and they're allowed one 90day uh EX
exension time frame to replace
this and representative if I could add
um we do have a few cases where you know
we we go to enforcement to require
someone to replace their system um you
know if it's if they're not doing it
willingly anyone else on the committee
for a
question seeing
none thank you very
much thank you very much for your
time thank you com
uh there's I think there was two people
to Bob Quinn and Sarah Holland did you
allow to talk speak together
yes the New Hampshire
Realtors good afternoon my name is Bob
Quinn I am the CEO of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors I'm Sarah
Holland I'm the vice chair of public
policy for the New Hampshire of realter
and first and foremost I wanted to take
a moment to thank representative rung um
she did reach out to the association
last fall uh we engaged in a a lengthy
uh very substantive conversation uh on
on this issue which also then prompted
uh the association to contact the
Department of Environmental Services
because I think that there's one thing
that both Dees as well as the Realtor
Association agree on is that the current
statute is not working the way it was
likely intended to work uh it is not
working for buyers it's not working for
Sellers and it's doing little to protect
uh public Waters um so over the past
month uh we have had some uh very
productive good conversations with
department environmental services again
thank uh Mr trobridge for uh always U
being available to answer questions and
to work with us uh we had hope that
perhaps we'd have something to submit
today we're not quite ready there uh but
if there is a work session I'm confident
that we come together and present
something to you whether or not it's for
this bill or for a future legislative
session um to resolve some of these
issues because it is a priority for us
as well in protecting the public Waters
as well as ensuring that buyers and
sellers have a smooth uh transaction and
with that I'm going to turn over to
Sarah who can go over some of our
concerns with the specifics of the bill
as
written um thank you again um and I did
want to point out that um I have sat on
the Lakes management advisory committee
and I was a part of the cyanobacteria
advisory committee as well I not against
public Waters um but in order to move
the needle I think we can do this in a
in a more efficient manner so I will
quickly point out the sections um that
and summarize our concerns there so in
section
one the definition of developed
Waterfront is changing to include
Parcels of land within 250 ft to bring
it in line with Shoreland protection
protection act which extends to 50 so
does make sense however it would make
more sense if that definition of
developed Waterfront said septic systems
not property because properties as you
know in New Hampshire can be very vast
so a property maybe has water Frontage
but the septic system can be several
Acres away from that Waterfront so we
would make that
recommendation number two in section two
we do think some objective standard
should be included so that if a town
wants to um add more stringent standards
that they may be um that they may be
required to present some sort of
scientific standards explaining why de's
standards are not adequate this is to
ensure that the town ordinance is the
result of environmental concern and not
just a way to restrict new
development section three titled sewage
Disposal system site assessment study
the bigest biggest issue here is that
section D states that a detailed septic
evaluation needs to be performed by a
septic system designer in New Hampshire
septic evaluations the review of septic
systems the digging up um of the tank
and looking maybe perhaps with cameras
at the system these are done um by
evaluators not
designers so septic evaluators perform
evaluations designers perform site
assessments which are fairly
non-invasive and again we think um we
understand the sponsors and DS Dees um
objective but there might be a better
way here and then finally in section
five relative to system
failure this paragraph would prohibit
the property from closing until the
system was repaired or replaced and as
the sponsor had mentioned she is open to
um timelines relative to that but this
um language is very similar almost
identical to Massachusetts Title 5
septic requirement which also prevents
properties from transferring so um the
cost and delay of closing um does little
to prevent the contamination into water
bodies so we think there is another way
to go about this um
but to bring you into a buyer
perspective most buyers unless they are
going to um completely demolish and
start over um they are likely not going
to want to proceed and will either
request the seller to replace or remedy
the tank or they will exit the
transaction in which the seller now has
an obligation to share this information
going forward with any party um
so what our language does in this bill
or the language in the bill does is also
eliminates relative to Massachusetts
Title 5 um it eliminates any sort of
financial assistance um for the property
owner um who may not have known that
their property their septic system was
in Failure um and now is now required to
replace it which can be tens of
thousands of dollars so um as uh Bob had
mentioned we are in conversations with
Dees and do um hope to come to um some
some agreement on some of these things
that actually do move the Needle happy
to take any
questions any questions by members of
the committee
representative Bale followed by
representative
lontine
else um thank you Mr chair I'm just
looking at
um you said um about the amendment so
you would be open to an amendment on the
bill absolutely
yes representative l
montain
thank you Mr shair and thank you for
taking my question um are there buyers
of shorel properties now that are waving
inspections of the septic that you
know so that it does happen um it is
generally not the norm in the situations
in which it is happening it is generally
a buyer that has the means to do any
replacement of those systems so they're
not finding it to be a financial concern
in their transac
a followup or
followup and with regards to the
massachusett law U do you feel that if
we did have an amendment to say to give
the
seller if they discover that they're
buying a interested in buying a property
with a failed septic that the seller
would have six months to repair the
septic system that would take the
pressure off I mean the I'm sorry the
Buy would then um have six months to fix
it that would take the pressure off the
seller being forced to come up with the
month advance in order to the for the
property to be sold it could be a
consideration for stakeholders I think
the concern there is um if if that's
something that the buyer is in agreement
with that's great if the buyer is not in
agreement with it then the seller still
retains the property and still has the
septic system that they now have
knowledge of that needs to be replaced
that puts them in that same financial
situation Kelly the
next no representative harb is after you
representative harb then repres thank
you um thank you for taking my question
um title five as I understand it in
Massachusetts because I'm a
transactional attorney says that the
seller has to do the inspection but
there can be negotiated between the
seller and the buyer who does the repair
and the upgrade and I believe it gives
them a year does the board of realtors
do you have any suggestion or any
opinions regarding how long someone
should have whether it's the buyer or
seller to repair the
system without speaking with my
stakeholders in this moment I I like the
idea of the latitude of either party
instead of a mandate on one or the other
um and understanding our season
the longer the amount of time the
better thank
you of Derby thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question I'm wondering
if the um Realtors see um concern from
potential buyers about
cyanobacteria and eoli um closures to
Lake to lakefront properties which are
happening more and more across the
state think the health of the water body
when buyers are looking to purchase
property is part of their diligence in
that process
yes representative Kelly then
representative
Bale thank you Mr chair I had two
questions and I was hoping someone else
would ask one so I only had to ask
one I get questions very easy so uh my
first question like uh can you guys give
us some idea about uh
the cost of like this like let's say a
seller selling a property they find a
broken septic system do we have any
numbers on cost of like a quick septic
repair that could finish a real estate
transaction so this this is not my my um
area of expertise but what I have
observed in in my career is it kind of
runs the gamut right so something like
um
uh an old dbox that is um maybe
crumbling and needs to have a um a new
poured concrete box around it couple
hundred dollar easy fix complete
replacement of a septic system to bring
in a designer to go through the
permitting process and then to have it
installed those are so those are three
parties for if you include Dees that are
involved in that the evaluator the
designer and the installer um that could
be upwards of $50,000 or more depending
on the location of the
property a followup followup and then my
second question followup this question
second question I'll ask a followup
first then I'll ask for a permission
from the chair so so the followup to
that is is you know we're talking short
front property you know and we're
talking 2023 so you know do we have how
about a number about the median house
price sale price on a shorefront
property so we need to be careful when
we think about shorefront because I
think a lot of the times we're thinking
about Lake winnipauk multi-million
dollar homes this provision um of
developed waterfront property is along
um any body of water great ponds that
are 10 acres or more fourth order
greater Rivers um and tidal waters so
that could very rural properties so the
costs replace a septic system is can be
um that where they had no intention or
even understanding that they were
considered you know kind of a developed
waterfront property um can be
devastating to a property
owner I appreciate it coming from burin
I totally get that it's the definitely
the I was I was guilty of the BL winter
Baki thing okay question quick quick one
more question about
all right it's it's it's only your
ranking member you're
blocking the second question unrelated
is this this debate over septic
installers versus evaluators because
we've had that before been in this
committee for three years now four years
now that's something we hear a lot so
can you detail the difference between
the two my understanding was the
installer the evaluators were a
private process versus the designer was
a a Dees run program but it could be so
my again outside of my scope but um my
understanding is one person can be all
three right um but that the eval the
septic system evaluators fall under oplc
and their licensing and the designers
fall under the purview of Dees so they
have two very different functions but I
think it's also important just to
clarify that what we're talking about in
this legislation currently and the
statute it's uh the septic designers
which are doing the site assessments and
those are
mandated I think it is fair to say and
Sarah Will C me if I'm wrong that in
almost every transaction that occurs the
buyer also has a septic evaluation done
and the septic evaluation I think is and
I think that there's some agreement on
this uh among the parties is going to
provide a lot more information about
whether or not not the system is
operational and functioning properly or
not um than a site assessment does so
that's kind of one of the areas that we
think that there's some areas to to
improve representative V thank you Mr
chair um thank you for taking my
question are there buyers purchasing
Shoreland property and waving
inspections right now that you know of
yeah that does happen it does happen it
it's generally not the norm and
definitely in this market where things
have changed over the last 12 months um
that we're seeing a return of folks
holding on to those buyer rights to be
able to do those um in in past markets
like we saw throughout the pandemic um
it was generally a a competition um
scenario where in order to obtain the
property get it under contract that they
needed to wave those not that they
wanted to follow up or a followup
um so a
buyer a buyer can um purchase a property
that has a failed septic system as it is
right now correct thank you remind the
committee we've got 15 minutes left and
I have the cards
uh I think I see no more
questions thank
you uh
Andrea Laro from New Hampshire
Lakes good afternoon again I'm Andrea
lamro president of New Hampshire Lakes
again New Hampshire Lakes We a Statewide
nonprofit organization representing
about 275 Lake Associations and uh a
couple thousand Lake enthusiasts
uh thank you for this opportunity um New
Hampshire Lakes we um are in support of
this bill and we're supportive of uh the
types of amendments that representative
Rong um was speaking about and um I
would I'm just going to build upon
recognizing um we're been here a while
recogn uh build upon representative rang
and de's comments uh we are we agree
with all the reasons they've expressed
for why um this is a good idea one thing
I'm going to share with with you uh
today is on January 3rd of this year I
testified in front of the Senate finance
committee on what Bill number was I've
been to a lot so far um s SP
394 this bill appropriates 1 million to
the
cyanobacteria uh mitigation Grant and
Loan Fund and this I know is a uh a fund
that this committee was supportive last
year and and it eventually got included
um into the state budget but we won't go
go into that but I so I spoke in support
of this appropriation and they asked me
a number of questions um doing their due
deligence but one of the questions they
asked me is and I'm going to paraphrase
a little bit here they
said you know we're we're a little
uncomfortable continuing to give money
to this fund if there isn't things being
done there aren't thing things being
done that are really getting at reducing
the sources of this pollution that's
contributing to these cyanobacteria s
and I said well thank you so much for
asking this question and I was pleased
to let them know that there are a
handful of bills being considered in the
legislature this session that are a
direct result of the
cyanobacteria um Advisory Group that
helped to Dees produce the CYO bacteria
plan and this and they specifically
asked me what are we doing about
fertilizer and I let them what what are
we doing about septic systems and um
so when I mentioned to them that there's
this bill um and that there's you know
an attempt to uh reduce the septic
system pollution uh to our Lakes which
contributes to these cyanobacteria bills
they were encouraged there were other
bills fertilizer Bill and another of of
them but I can understand not wanting to
throw you know more and more money at
this fund to help Lake
Associations remediate these blooms if
we as a state aren't wor working
together to reduce the sources of this
pollution so I'm really encouraged today
to hear that um you know the various
stakeholders in this room are interested
in working together I heard that you
know we all agree that the current
system is is not working when a Property
Transfers hands it's not very
informative um it's certainly not
protective of water quality
so I really urge this committee um
hopefully in work session and with
potential amend M ments to really it as
representative rung said this issue of
septic systems has come up again and
again and again and we can't wait any
longer our Lakes are having more and
more cyanobacteria blooms we've got to
do something for public health for our
investments along our Lakes for our
economy uh for recreation for tourism so
I urge you to uh support this bill in a
way that the the the various groups in
this room can um work together on an
amendment that will actually result in
some positive
change and with that i' would be happy
to answer any
questions I have BL first are you saying
that the Senate hasn't read the cyano
bacteria plan I made sure that they had
a copy of it God after all the work we
did I made sure they knew about it thank
you uh repres representative
Bale I just wanted to say thank you for
staying on the cause here and I'm just
sitting here in front of my report from
the New Hampshire Shoreland septic
system study commission which produced
this report four years ago and I'm glad
that we're here today looking at what we
can do this um at the time this report
was released there were 65 impaired
lakes and I'm curious to find out if we
know how many there are
now
that thank you for the question and uh
if if you're specific lakes that are
impaired for water quality reasons um I
don't know that specific information and
and certainly I could get that to you
from Dees or perhaps someone from Dees
in the room has that information
today so
much probably the
next there any other questions
any see seeing none thank you very much
thank
you uh Glenn
Rogers from Friends of hot hole
Pond thanks very much for uh letting me
say a few words um we uhu I do represent
uh the friends of Haro Pond which is uh
very informal
Lake
Association uh back in 2017 we did have
a cyano bacteria Bloom and that's when
uh our organization uh started to U
think about what kinds of things we
might we might do and we we worked with
the uh Department of Environmental
Services uh we did a septic system
survey of the 25 properties around uh
our little Pond um and uh we also worked
with New Hampshire Lakes um and an
application for our property to be to be
Lakes smart and as a result of that we
had a septic system
evaluator which was very
helpful and not very
expensive two2 200
$250 and they uh U noticed that there
were three small improvements that
needed to be done to the system um and
uh we had that done for again a fairly
modest amount of money we did not have a
designer uh work with us uh we uh
inquired about a designer they're much
more
expensive uh than an evaluator and the
evaluator that we had did a really
wonderful job of specifically telling us
what the three um things we could do to
make our septic system full fully
operational so uh to have those kinds of
evaluations not necessarily a designer I
think uh when someone uh is in process
of of uh selling their property just
makes a lot of sense to us and I'm sure
many of our small Lake Associations
would see that as making a lot of sense
to improve the environmental health of
our of our ponds it just makes a lot of
common sense uh so I I certainly uh
would support this bill and would be
glad to take any questions you might
have questions for members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you Pat tarpy from Lake
winaki
Association thank you members of the
committee Pat tarpy president of the
Lake Winn basaki
Association um I want to speak
specifically to a septic system
Improvement program that we ran several
years back which might answer some of
the questions I heard here earlier um we
worked with the town of Meredith who
wanted to adopt a health regulation to
address septic systems within 250 ft of
Lake wuan it took over 10 years to get
that Health ordinance passed there was a
lot of educ done but at the time Lin
abaki Association obtained two grants uh
one from the source water protection
program and one through Dees 319 program
the first through the source waterer was
because walk youan is a drinking water
source for the business community of
Meredith as well as some
residents and Meredith had done some
investigation and they realized there
were many properties that didn't have
operational approvals and that were very
old and with and within the 250 ft
shorel
Zone um we did a caare program to have
and we hired one US licensed septic
system evaluator who conducted all the
evaluations so as Apples to Apples we
opened it up to any property over 25
years old so they didn't have to have
they could have an operational approval
or whatever and they didn't even have to
be subject to Meredith Health ordinance
because we opened it up to New Hampton
and Center Harbor which also border
wyan I can tell you and I have numbers
and I submitted this testimony there
were
183 um shorefront properties within that
250 foot Zone
95 which is
52% had systems that were installed
prior to 1988 which would make them 25
years old or old older at the time we
did this
program uh it was a voluntary program 29
evaluations were
conducted and of the 29 18 systems were
found to be in failure that's 62% of
those
evaluated we had the second uh grant
program was which was a c share program
and let me just say the evaluations cost
500 our grant paid 250 the property
owner paid 250
um we had a second Grant which for those
properties found in Failure we would
provide cost share up to $4,000 to
repair or
replace so we also through our watershed
management plans we do a septic system
risk analysis so we we look at we get
all the properties within 250 feet of
the area we're studying and we base it
are they seasonal are they year around
what's the age of the
building which is not necessarily
indicative of the septic but right now
we're doing wolfboro Bay and I can tell
you there are 284 Parcels that fall
within that 250t
boundary 21 of them that's 74% are 25
years or older the
buildings most of these properties at
least on wiip are seasonal second
home s
and I'm thinking age is very indicative
of the age of the septic but we have
found through what we've done age of the
septic is the number one factor
determining factor of whether the system
is going to be in Failure we support
this bill um and we urge you to pass
this and I'll take any
questions any questions from members of
the committee seeing none very
much last uh the last uh card I have uh
Melissa
py from conservation law
Foundation thank you so much thank you
for allowing me to thank turn it on
there we go that's better thank you so
much to the committee um for giving me a
moment to make some comments my name is
Melissa paly I'm the Great Bay piscatqua
Water keeper with conservation law
foundation and um I know a lot of the
folus here and a lot of the proponents
of this uh represent uh
freshwater um interests the Lakes
Association and so on and it's fantastic
to see so many people turning out I want
to put a word in for the coastal part of
the state um and uh the saltwater end of
New Hampshire uh which is equally uh
threatened by um pollution from septic
systems and it's the reason why I felt
it was important to come out and support
this uh bill which I think is is a very
small but important step um toward uh
protecting uh New Hampshire's uh Water
Resources um as I mentioned uh I commend
the committee for recognizing the
serious impact of septic systems on
water quality and ecosystem Health um
and as uh representative Vale noted um
nearly three well three and three and a
half years ago after a year of study uh
Judith spangs representative spangs
legislative study Commission on
Shoreland septic systems um uh submitted
a final report I was a member of that
commission um and we had a a slew of
recommendations that came out of that
that recognized that both nitrogen and
phosphorus uh from septic systems uh
negatively impact freshwater in uh
Coastal rivers and Bays um so uh but let
me focus on the Sea Coast for a minute
where I focus my efforts to to protect
and restore the health of the Great Bay
um Estuary nitrogen pollution from
septic systems is a very serious concern
um according to the 2018 state of our
estories report uh the Great Bay estor
has three times the nitrogen load um
that it should have to be protective of
estrine Health uh the more recent state
of our estories report just released in
June
2023 um indicates that the point sources
of nitrogen those coming from wastewater
treatment facilities has declined to uh
levels that we haven't seen since we
started recording nitrogen um in the
great Bast this is a cause for great
celebration that is because
municipalities around the Great Bay
Region have invested so many millions of
dollars in upgrading wastewater
treatment facilities so what it means
now is that our excess nitrogen load is
largely due to storm water and septic
systems um around the Great Bay Region
we have tens of thousands of them uh
about half of the population our 400,000
people that live in the Great Bay
Watershed uh use septic systems um for
their waste waste disposal and um to the
best estimates that we have from a 2014
report called the Great Bay nitrogen
non-point Source study which I think U
uh Mr trobridge had something to do with
um we estimate that about onethird of
the nitrogen pollution coming uh into
the grape astery is coming um from
septic systems onethird of the non-point
source so the onethird of the the stuff
that's not coming from wastewater
treatment facilities is coming from
septic systems so as I noted there's
been a lot of regulatory focus on
nitrogen pollution from wastewater
treatment facilities those run by our 18
mun of the municipalities in the Great
Bay but very little attention paid uh to
improving uh septic system
infrastructure and um so while the
volume of the discharge from every
individual SE system is rather small the
concentration of nitrogen and phosphorus
can be as much as 10 times higher than
what's coming out of a wastewater
treatment facility so we're talking
about 30 40 50 um uh uh um uh micro
micrograms per liter this is very high
when we talk about wastewater treatment
facilities that are discharging five six
to eight you know micrograms per liter
so it's almost an or can be like an
order of magnitude more nitrogen and
phosphorus pollution coming from septic
system systems I think it's important to
recognize that it's not just failed
septic systems that are the source of
this pollution okay septic systems are
designed to to really were designed to
mitigate bacteria from leaving a
waste a Lee field and getting into a
water a drinking water well nitrogen and
phosphorus are very water soluble they
end up going right through the uh
through this the tank out into the Lee
field and largely getting into the
groundwater and moving from there into
to Wetland streams and so on and so that
is the secret the the little known
secret about septic systems is that they
really are not effective at reducing
this nitrogen and phosphorus that is the
cause of cyanobacteria blooms and the
freshwater and uh and uh a whole Cascade
of ufic in in our saltwater environments
some of that will um uh be um mitigated
by distance it will be up so there is
some uptake in soil and roots and so on
but it's why it's especially important
in this bill that we're expanding the
protective Zone from 200 to 250 ft and
indeed uh one of the recommendations in
the Shoreland septic system study
commission was to expand that to 600 ft
um that is what uh we believe is
actually the appropriate distance um
that would uptake that would mitigate a
lot of those nutrients from getting into
water waste so you're this bill expands
50 ft it's again it's a small step but
it's a step in the right
direction um another key finding in the
Shoreland septic system study commission
was how widespread the lack of awareness
is by homeowners about the condition the
maintenance needs even the location of
the septic system this out of sight out
of mine problem compounds the challenge
of reducing water quality impacts and
requiring a septic system in evaluation
at the time of a property transfer will
make septic systems more visible to the
new home buyers and provide
municipalities and Dees with more
additional information about septic
systems that are underperforming or are
intermittently problematic due to
changing groundwater levels periods of
more intense use and other variables
that are exacerbated by climate
change um so you know while some have
contended that such reviews at the time
of property transfer are already
universally conducted um at the ma the
representative of the of the banking
industry on the Shoreland septic system
study commission anecdotally reviewed uh
a set of loan agreements and found that
many lacked any documentation of septic
system assessment or evaluation so while
hopefully most people who are going into
a um a purchase do um do these kinds of
Assessments and evaluations uh I think
the reality is that many do not so as
I've noted I I believe that HB 11113
would take a very small step toward more
effective regulation of septic systems
to better protect the state's precious
uh saltwater and freshwater resources
from the threats of nutrient pollution
and I urge that uh you approve this and
I would support amendments as has been
discussed as well thank you and uh I
will submit these to your uh through
your online portal I'm happy to take any
questions if you have any thank you any
questions by members of the
committee seeing none thank you very
much
much that is the last uh P card that I
have uh with that I will close the uh
hearing on House Bill
close uh one minute to clear the room
and get the rest of the folks for the
one21 absolutely
mons I mention
Mass considering whatever whatever she
didn't
spoke about the science behind the
nutrients and that's not really we all
agree that that's it get in
the
yeah
and
e
startor repres let me do this again I
didn't have my thing
on starting house on House Bill
1121 care recognizes representative
Aaron thank you good afternoon um
members of resources Recreation and
development committee thank you so much
for having me come and introduce this
bill to you I am representative Judy
Aaron and I represent Sullivan County
District 4 representing the towns of
aworth Goan langden lster and
Washington I'm introducing this bill HB
1121 to you today having to do with
Wetland permit exemptions with regard to
natural disaster and flooding
situations this past summer in July 2023
as well as in July
2021 many towns experience flooding due
to heavy rains for property owners who
AB but or who have on their property
perennial or seasonal streams there were
instances of those streams Rivers Brooks
Etc being clogged up with debris and
diverting in such a manner as to cause
damage or threaten to cause damage to
their Gardens their animal pens
structures on their property and
farmland current law says that if you
want to clear out debris from a stream
River Brook
Etc that you need to get a permit from
Dees as described to me by Darlene
Forest of Dees Wetlands Bure Bureau
administrator and land resources
management Property Owners cannot
disturb a streamed without a Wetlands
permit yes you can also get an emergency
permit but these Dees permits are
expensive and cost a non-refundable $400
fee or more plus the homeowner has to
submit a plan for any stream work to be
done which can also be quite expensive
for the property owner especially if the
homeowner has to en engage an engineer
and so on the plan can be rejected by
Dees and then you've lost the permitting
fee and you have to start all over again
plus it can take a long time for the
permit to be approved by Dees and I
think it's outrageous for property
owners to go through this whether as an
emergency authorization or not the
simply want to clear out the debris that
is collected in their in the Stream um
as soon as possible um with as little as
little um disturbance as possible after
any kind of um uh flooding event or a
storm normally we go into our yards and
we clear out all kinds of sticks and
stuff that has been flying around we
should be able to do that with our
streams as well especially if it diverts
the uh the stream from uh from its
natural course and now uh the stream is
going in a different
direction Miss Forest informed me that a
property owner May remove certain Woody
debris from a riverbed but a Wetlands
permit would be required for
construction excavation and fill in a
wetlands jurisdictional area that being
said any Woody debris in question cannot
be embedded in the bed or Bank of the
river removing easily retrievable Woody
debris is not considered excavation and
therefore would not require Wetlands
permitting but you can't enter into the
river to remove the debris you need to
modify the bed or bank by the river if
you need to modify the bed or Bank of
the river for equipment access then that
access preparation might require a
permit as well so unless you can extract
the Woody debris from the perennial or
seasonal stream without going into the
river or somehow pick it out with a
crane then you don't need a
permit Dees provided me with a fact
sheet managing large Woody material in
rivers and streams which I've passed out
to all of
you it summarizes the provisions in our
statute RSA
482a and and the rules um from NHC EnV
WT 100 to 900 governing the removal of
debris which they call large wood large
Woody material um the fact sheet States
essentially that you can clear the
material if you own the land under the
stream or get the permission of the land
owner as long as you don't do anything
to disturb the riverbed or the banks if
the removal would disturb the riverbed
or Banks a permit is
required so what happens you so you can
pick out this Woody debris and get rid
of it and that's fine but what happens
to the rest of the material that's
clogging up your stream or your Brook
that needs to be removed in order for
the river to flow where it was flowing
before consider that the new course of
the perennial or seasonal stream is now
running over the banks and beginning new
erosion of what was previously not land
under the stream brook or river consider
that this new course of the river is
threatening your barn or your animal
pens or your
Gardens in that instance according to
the dees rules a property owner now
needs a whole engineering plan and a
$400 Dees permit to get the river back
back to ple to back to pre flood
conditions this bill that I'm offering
you today provides a property owner an
exemption for emergency perennial or
seasonal stream maintenance after a
natural disaster or flooding event and
allows for a restoration of the streamed
to pre-storm course conditions with this
bill a permit under RSA
482a shall not be required by Property
Owners under some following some some
circumstances
after a natural disaster or flooding
event when the course of a perennial or
seasonal stream on the property has been
altered due to debris buildup caused by
rocks Boulders silt or plant material
and the new course of the perennial or
seasonal stream threatens uh property
Gardens field crops livestock pens
fences or structures the property owner
May remove the blockage and allow the
stream to follow its original course the
property owner doesn't have to apply for
any permits shall not be subjected to
any fines or penalties for work done to
clear the debris buildup or blockage and
any work must be completed within 60
days after the natural disaster or
flooding event
occurs the property owner must document
the work done and include photo
documentation any work done may be done
by the property owner or a contractor if
the property owner does the work then a
local conservation officer should be
made aware of it and actually may offer
input to the planned work if the
property owner employs a contractor that
contractor must have experience with or
is familiar with New Hampshire Wetland
permitting and stream management
practices if the affected area of the
perennial or seasonal stream has a
Butters the property owner must contact
a Butters to the perennial or seasonal
stream in question and notify them of
the problem and the work that he's
planning to be done to clear the debris
and restore the course of this stream if
the affected area of the perennial
stream flows under a municipal bridge
then it is the responsibility of the
municipality to obtain any necessary
emergency Wetland permits and clear the
debris blockage or buildup if the
affected area of the perennial or
seasonal stream flows under the state
brid a state bridge then is the
responsibility of the state of
Department of Transportation to obtain
any necessary emergency Wetland permits
and clear the debris blockage or buildup
so I believe that
we need to implement some common sense
here a property owner shouldn't have to
jump through hoops pay a lot of money
for unref undable permits or wait months
for Dees permit approval in order to
Simply remove debris and blockages from
the streams on their
property the fear that a property owner
may not know what they're doing or may
make the problem worse or may just set
themselves up for the same thing to
occur again it's a tired argument but
with that in mind I've set Provisions in
the bill for people to be consulted for
the work that the property owner wants
to do to clear these blockages out of
the streams after a flooding event again
to me this is just common sense most of
the problems I've seen with flooding in
my
area is because there's been a sore
lacking of river and stream management
and I think it's the result of the
statutes we have in place and the dees
philosophy regarding this
their philosophy seems to be to leave
nature do its thing and that Rivers
streams and Brooks have their own
Natural Evolution and that we shouldn't
mess with it and that organisms develop
in those blockages and we shouldn't
disturb them well what about the
property owner and the aggravation they
have from a flooding event what about
the loss of
land the loss of physical property
because a perennial or seasonal stream
is changing course because of blockages
that happen after a flooding event the
truth is that leaving debris to
accumulate and allowing a river brook or
stream to go wherever it wants is not a
welcome idea for many Property Owners
the sooner a blockage is cleared out the
better then we don't allow for further
erosion of land where the streamer River
didn't go before and we aren't allowing
organisms and Wildlife or fish to set up
house there either why should a property
owner be saddled with dealing with
engineering plans and cumbersome
permitting the property owner just wants
to get the perennial stream or a
seasonal stream cleared out and back to
where it was as soon as
possible and as for a Dees emergency
provision allowing for permit exemptions
such that you can clear out these
streams during a flooding event how many
Property Owners will want to risk their
life and limb during a heavy rainfall to
clear out a raging River or Brook I
don't suspect
any in general our state Dees needs to
do better assess to needs to better
assess the amount of debris damage that
occurs in the affected streams after a
natural disaster or heavy rains we're
seeing streams with massive rocks and
debris from rain from the rains change
course because they're blocked up and
those streams never get cleared out or
dredged properly putting property
including historic buildings and Roads
at High higher risk for future natural
events this has happened specifically at
Bowers Brook in aworth town center where
now the brook is so blocked up that it's
threatening historical buildings
including our Village store which has
been flooded twice in the past four
years to their credit Dees and the state
do are assisting the town of aworth now
in fixing the problem but we live daily
with fears of more flooding until Dees
engineering Solutions and blockage
clearance is is
accomplished and um I'm I know we're
waiting we we we're uh forecasted for
two days of heavy rains next week so
we're worried that uh the stream is
going to jump its banks
again I've also seen buildup of debris
and naturally changing uh the naturally
changing nature of the Cold River
affecting VIIs pool in alad and that's
been going on for more than a decade
such that in the past two floods of July
2021 and July 2023 the Cold River jumped
its banks and took out portions of Route
123a the town of alad should be dredging
that area in a VIIs pool but the permit
and Engineering costs have been too much
for the town to bear so the problem just
keeps getting worse and as I said we
need to do a better job of understanding
and more importantly implementing stream
management after rains rain events
happen the same goes for management of
beaver bogs as they tend to break after
heavy rains and have caused Great damage
ditto for our dams both Municipal and
private so I hope that you'll consider
what I've presented today listen to some
of the testimony people who have dis
been disaffected by the current
permitting rules and pass this bill out
of your committee it's time that we give
Property Owners a break especially in a
time when they have a huge issue an
expense in front of them to clean up
Damage Done by their on their land by
natural disasters and flooding so I'd be
happy to take any questions that you
have
um and um I'm thankful that you listened
today I did know that there were a
couple of people who planned on uh
submitting testimony through the portal
so I hope that you will uh check out
what was written online as
well any questions by members of the
committee representative
Derby thank you Mr chair uh thank you
representative Aaron for my question
um there's a few terms in the bill that
I'm concerned about but I'd like to just
focus on one um last last year we heard
uh a bill about natural disasters and
one of the big concerns about that bill
was the lack of definition of natural
disaster this um that bill required um
Dees to Define rules related to natural
disasters but as I read this this allows
the property owner to take action based
on what might be their uh understanding
of a natural disaster so as a natural
dis can you describe what a natural
disaster is to you and how a property
owner would um distinguish an event
where they can remedy the situation on
their own versus uh you know a half an
inch of rain thank
you well it would appear to me I think
just in common sense for for first for
starters um I'm I'm happy to amend this
bill to change any wording that um more
clearly defines a
situation um but that being said I think
that Common Sense can dictate that the
difference between you know a couple of
inches of rain and an actual flooding
that happens where water jumps over the
banks um or is going in in places where
it really was not before um where where
water is coming now uh threatening um
animal pens and and barns and things
like that um we're seeing heavier rains
coming um more flooding happening and um
I think
that people are aware that damage can be
done as a result of um you know more
precipitation so I think just common
sense dictates that um
you know this is not an a thing where
two inches of rain
happens representative
R thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
noticed in the bill it mentions about um
notifying AB Butters to the perennial or
seasonal stream would is your intent
that those abutters would also abut the
property of the person who is going to
be doing the clearance ing because there
might be a stream that could be a mile
or so long so would would all the
abutters have to be notified all
Downstream I think just the the um the
immediate the abutters that are
immediate to the area that is being
affected so that um you know if you have
a stream that's running on your property
and and
it's you have a butter right next door
um basically get in touch with your
neighbor who is who is uh abing that
stream and let them
know okay followup or followup
yeah I I I think you know if we looked
at this bill that might be something
that we'd want to specify some more
because if I lived a half a mile down
stream I would consider myself in a
butter and if I was affected you know I
just think maybe we could kind of firm
that up a little bit but um and i' be
happy to do that yeah okay thank you um
but also we have a letter here from Dees
and it kind of touches upon the area of
the bill that talks about um notifying
or she'll document where is it um it's
about bring in the conservation officer
and what what role do you see with the
conservation officer as uh someone who
who is familiar with the wetlands um
management and who can offer some
advice um to the to the property owner
okay um because one of the concerns is
maybe the conservation officer doesn't
have that background that maybe they're
just for law enforcement of the
conservation laws so that might be
something too that could be getting
someone with more expertise I guess
um well I would assume that if they are
familiar with the
rules uh and the and the and the rsas
having to do with stream
management that those are the laws that
they are enforcing I would assume that
they would have some knowledge of um
being able to give some advice as to
what would be prudent to do and not
prudent to do okay thank you and you
know I mean
listening oh just one just just
listening to your testimony I am
empathetic I mean that that is a tough
situation for those owners thank you Mr
chair uh you mentioned a letter from D
which one are you talking
about the one signed by commissioner
Scott it's titled um relative to HB 1121
an act relative to creating certain What
lands permit exemptions dated the
16th I don't have that either right you
got it is this one with River maner
no it's it's signed by commissioner
Scott email did it get hung
up yeah
representative I don't know did it get
anywhere Beyond
[Music]
there you got one what if where is there
any up
there
is it maybe is that it there okay
uh we'll blame representative Simpson
she's not
here okay there you go I guess it goes
down thank you representative Derby for
a question thank you again Mr chair
thanks again for taking my
question just I have a a question about
just some of
the wording that it says the property
owner shall document the work done and
may include photo documentation what
what's your thought behind that like
what are they going to do how are they
going to what's going to H happen with
that documentation so that they can show
what the um what the condition was after
the
flooding and then show what their remedy
was to to put the stream back to where
it was before just to have uh something
to show that um they had done something
to put the stream back to where it was
for a followup thank you um would they
submit this someplace or would they keep
it I'm just I'm curious I guess they
could keep it for themselves I could
submit it to the town um unless Dees
comes by and wants to see something okay
at least they have something that shows
what the condition was after the
flooding event and um and what they did
to uh put that stream back or clear that
blockage out I mean you know the thing
is we have we have these these uh
flooding events and I I know that there
are people in my town who this has
happened to they have a stream we have a
lot of water in hackworth um we we have
streams that that get blocked up with
stuff
and I I know that there are people who
are going out there and clearing these
streams anyway without a permit if they
can't be seen by the road they're going
to clear it out because they want to
protect their livestock pens or whatever
is being threatened by the change of the
riverbed and um and it's the folks who
you can see their their stuff by the
road that are the ones that are being
monitored and there's somewhat of a of
an unfairness here
too um that's going on and um
excuse me I I just think that it's just
common sense if you have a stream that
wasn't blocked before now it's blocked
up and it's causing damage somewhere
just go out and clear it out I mean this
it doesn't seem like it's rocket science
it's just get it cleared out and let the
stream go back to the the natural course
of where it was before without waiting
months for a a a plan to be approved
without cost of $400 for a permit
without having to go to town hall and
submit things and duplicate triplicate I
mean why do we have to deal with this
whole big bureaucratic mess then just go
out and take care of the problem and get
it
fixed any other questions by members of
the
committee seeing
none much thank
you representative Brian
Sullivan speaking in favor
good
afternoon Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Brian Sullivan um I
represent Sullivan County district one
which is um my fine town of Grandam
um I am not here because I am ex an
expert on Wetlands um if you ask me some
technical questions I can prove that um
however I am here because I believe this
is a problem that really needs a
solution um and if this bill as drafted
is not exactly what will solve the
problem then I urge you to um this
committee to access the resources that
are at your disposal to to find a way to
um mitigate um these ever more common um
serious floods and it's not just
Sullivan County we we got really nailed
naed last summer um but um gorm got
nailed a couple weeks ago um so it's U
it it's a problem across the state and
um people need to be able to um to
protect uh vulnerable property and um
I'm just here to urge you to find a
solution you know I saw one of the
letters of uh uh lobbying the um
committee said let's let's start a study
um I urge you to find a solution as soon
as possible because uh next
summer I would bet anything we will have
another series of floods um they are
just coming more and more frequently so
um um I can't give you the solution
because again it's not my area of
expertise but there are folks um within
Dees and um um other folks who you have
access to that can find a way to
streamline this process because if as
people wait weeks and weeks to mitigate
a problem um the rain comes in again and
the problem gets that much worse so um
um I there is one um area within the
bill that I would suggest um a
modification would be um
appropriate in line
seven it refers to um property Gardens
field crops livestock pens fences or
structures um when you lead that off
with the word property um that basically
covers all property and I don't think it
was the intention of this um um Bill to
uh cover the corner of a wood lot um so
I I I believe the idea is to uh protect
sensitive property not any and all
property that might exist um so that's I
think deleting the word property um and
if there's other type of sensitive
property that the committee feels
appropriate to add to that um I think
that's fine but just using the word
property means you know any piece of
land would would be included um so with
that um I'll end my testimony and I hope
I don't have to take any
questions I don't see
any
who
will you take a question from
representative Darby absolutely SP it's
spell your name for who he
remembers thank you Mr chair um thank
you genuinely for taking my question um
and of course as representative rung
said a minute ago um it's it's clear
that they're you know it's it's very
easy to be empathetic to the problems um
and your statement about a problem in
need of solution I wonder um there's
some existing statutes for um allowing
the commissioner to adopt rules to
either wave um uh uh permits in certain
conditions or expedite them and I wonder
if that would when you ask the committee
to to search for a solution if you would
be um willing to consider rules adopted
under those statutes for these
situations my understanding is and again
I'm not familiar with the Department um
that much my understanding is the
department has been reluctant to to uh
expedite this to the extent that uh I
believe might be needed so um I'm not
sure that Ru making would uh would get
the job
done thank you very
much Darlene forced
for Environmental
Services the the got to Chang his name
between now and
good afternoon again my name is Darlene
Forest I'm the current Wetlands buau
administrator previously Shoreline
section supervisor for the de New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services thank you for um allowing me
this time to testify on this bill on
behalf of the
department
um I think there's something that we all
very much can agree on I've as I said
previously we've submitted a risent
testimony on behalf of the department
you don't need me to read that to
you we have been hit as a state
approximately every six months by a
major flood event for the last three
years and they are devastating and some
regions have been hit twice maybe even
three times there is no question that
this is more than some towns can be
expected to handle when you lose this
much infrastructure or for private
property owners to deal
with um I think we can all agree on
that I do want to clarify some things as
representative Aaron stated you do not
need a permit to remove Woody
debris in part due to those Lost Years
of 2020 and
2021 we have not had a lot of out
Outreach and education to
dpws people didn't get together in 2020
so we didn't have training of town
officials in the aftermath in the labor
market we've had we're hearing a lot
that towns have lost their entire DPW
sections they can't find
people what this means is towns don't
always know what they can and can't do
this is one of our biggest hurdles
because the simple fact of the matter is
all of these Bridges and all of these
culs that are currently block locked up
with Woody debris when we see them we
are the ones who are saying oh my gosh
please get in there and get that out no
you cannot take please do not take heavy
equipment into the stream bed you can
take it onto the crossing you can take
it into the immediately adjacent areas
if we needed to give someone emergency
authorization to get them in there we
could do that that is not a formal
application process well we do have a
form there is no fee there is no butter
notification there is no engineer
required if you need temporary access to
get in there and clear something by all
means we have a process to do that in
the aftermath of an event we very
strongly recommend clean your culverts
and crossings speaking of that county of
the state some of you may have been here
and may remember that when the Cold
River had its first extreme flood of the
last oh decade 15 years it wasn't
because just of a rain event it was an
unmaintained
Culvert that could have been maintained
there was no rules keeping it from being
maintained it had simply been neglected
we understand that it is for this reason
that we have an entire section of our
rules already existing which if you
would like to look it up is Environ EnV
environmental en v- WT as in Wetlands
315 these are our emergency procedures
in accordance with
3154 those are things where if in the
aftermath of an event you notice that
there is damage to a structure that
needs repair you can send us photographs
and an email and a phone call and we
will provide the paper approval a paper
copy that you can then submit if you
need to submit paperwork to to FEMA for
funding so that you have the legal
cover section
3155 clearly states that in the actual
event and it was mentioned what is a
disaster um it's a disaster if you're in
the middle of it frankly most of our
stuff hasn't been Statewide and please
consider that when the governor declares
a disaster he declares it after the
event in accordance with federal
regulations based on the amount of
funding there is no in the moment no one
knows nor do we expect someone to think
do I have a disaster declaration yet
because you don't have time because
you're trying to protect your people or
you're trying to protect your property
that is not an exp expectation that we
have if there is an imminent risk to
people and property that is how it is
written one is imminent the other is
immediate if there's immediate risk our
rules say do the work you need to do to
mitigate the risk we don't figure
anybody's going to do much more than
what's necessary to mitigate the risk
because you don't have time especially
if you're a town or a DPW who has
multiple Crossings who are at risk or
multiple resources you might be
Emergency Services if you emergency
services and you've got alarms going off
all over town for people who are
stranded you can only do what is
necessary in each spot you're not going
to do more but our rules clearly state
in the event do what you need to do
to secure the
situation and then you report afterwards
we have noted that our rules currently
say towns have 10 days to report private
individuals have 30 days to report we
will be changing that it doesn't make
sense that the towns only have by rule
10 days to be quite honest we have been
taking Town reports from the 2021
floods and we are not pursuing any
ramifications if a town is reporting
their 2021 emergency damage to us
because they have to in order to qualify
for FEMA Aid we are simply accepting it
and giving them the acknowledgement
letter they need to complete their FEMA
applications we have been working very
closely of late
with uh particularly eight New Hampshire
home land Security emergency management
to try to provide better tools and
better education on these issues it all
is going to come down to education um
and it needs to be pre-education because
you're not going to learn about it in
the
moment we are developing an
online reporting tool for the after
action reports to come into us which
will allow us to expedite the response
to folks to get them the paperwork they
need which says yes during the event you
needed to do this you met the law when
you did it we have offered that we
currently have uh New Hampshire dot user
testing that that is going to go live
this spring um we are working out the
bugs so those rules that we have they're
not new they're about 30 years old the
problem is actually that no one even
knew they were there we have we have not
had a chance to let the dpws the folks
who are on the front lines know about it
the other aspect of this in regards to
your um your Fields your your vegetable
corn fields hay Fields your
barns if the river jumps
Channel and cuts a new channel I can
give you an example from this last event
Gentleman on the Enders
scogan Golf Course
asked if you could build the berm along
the top of the river as the Water
started to come
up he built the BM across the prop of
the river cross it was not in our
jurisdiction the answer was absolutely
if you think you can put a dyke in to
protect your
property he they attempted to get this
done that River still cut a swath across
this gentleman's golf course it
is unspeakable the damage that it did
and I don't know what they're going to
do it cut a new channel that channel is
dry now that's not our
jurisdiction the damage one of the other
aspects that we need to explain and that
we need to educate folks on is if it
dumped debris if the river cut a new
channel but that channel is not the new
wet
Channel then we are not exerting
jurisdiction over that channel if the
river cut a new channel and that is now
the wet
Channel then I would refer folks to the
example that
happened
roughly 2005 2006 on the Suncook River
in Epsom and Chai
Chester and if you think a homeowner is
going to go out and fix that that River
Channel bed dropped 32
feet in these flood events when you are
dealing with River Dynamics the reason
the long-term solution has an engineer
is because once the river gets out of
its Channel and it hits material that
has not previously been subject to those
forces it is very
Dynamic if it actually jumps and cuts a
new
channel then before you put it back you
probably have a little research to do
about how you're going to actually keep
it from going which is now the lower
elevation
Channel and how you're going to
stabilize where it's make sure it it
stays in its in its
previous um that is no little no
homeowners going going to do that no no
enterprising farmer is going to do that
um and if they do and it
fails we live in a very litigious
society and that's the other reason that
they're not going to do it it's because
nobody wants to get it
wrong so yes it is an exceptionally we
are as a state taking it on the chin and
we are taking it on the chin
repeatedly um
um we need to do a better job of
educating about what can and cannot be
done in the moment before the moment
gets here as Preparatory work that Woody
debris uh seriously I've seen enough
photos in the last six months where we
are horrified by what is still out there
in Channel and it needs to come out we
also understand that there is a fear not
of our permitting what we're hearing is
anything we do if FEMA doesn't if FEMA
doesn't think it was legal they won't
pay for it and then we can't afford the
funds we don't have everybody is cash
wrapped um what we hear the feedback we
hear as an agency it's not about what it
takes for us to get the permit because
in the moment you don't need the permit
and in the moment you don't you're not
going to have an
engineer the problem is um people are
afraid to take action if it puts their
ability for funding at risk because they
don't have a tax base to pay for the
damages that their towns are taking to
their
infrastructure um as individual home
homeowners what we hear most often is
can you help it's not how do I get a
permit it's can you direct me to help so
we get this um our as a department our
position on this is we've already got
rules in place that say you don't need a
permit for these things they're there
it's very unfortunate and we need to do
a better job in combination with
HSM conservation commissions any group
that we can find to let people know how
to handle
this um but those rules are already in
place
so the only thing that we see risk of
this statute is that it damages folks
ability to provide the paperwork that
they need to apply for their FEMA funds
and it damages their ability to be
covered under our Cooperative agreements
with the US Army Corps of Engineers and
these are definitely rivers and streams
unquestionably these are jurisdictional
areas um so their Dynamic systems the
long-term repair of these and the
long-term management of these should be
done in a coordinated Manner and yeah
there's probably another there's
probably another conversation that needs
to be had long term about how do we
coordinate
efforts to best manage these situations
to make sure our Crossings are properly
sized so they don't blow out in two
consecutive storm
events um to
prioritize the sequencing of Culvert
Replacements so that you don't upssize
the Upstream culverts before you upssize
the downstream CTS there's a lot of
planning that needs to
happen um and there's a lot of
discussion about how we fund these
things but I can tell you right now that
the exemption that this would give you
already exists it's
there
um the only thing you would do is is
jeopardize the recovery efforts based on
what we have currently with our our
federal Partners in this I do also want
to State one other thing just for the
record more often than not when you're
dealing with the stream you're not
dealing with the butters you're dealing
with land owners because the profit
property line is the center line of the
Stream So when you're going in to dig
out the middle of the stream half of
that belongs to somebody else assuming
you stay parallel to your own property
it's not just this isn't just um your
land and if the person on the other side
of the stream doesn't agree with
it or they're afraid that you know if
the river jump towards you and away from
them and they're afraid that it's going
to come back this also is not going
going to this just going to lead to more
disagreements so I appreciate and as a
department we all appreciate where this
is coming from and we have all heard um
some really tragic
stories and there is a problem to be
solved we are do not support this bill
because we do not believe it actually
advances us toward that solution and I
would be happy to take any questions you
may
have representative har
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
questions your letter or the letter says
that RSA 482a provides for work in
jurisdictional areas without permits I
heard talk and I have a handout about
large Woody material that is in the
Stream or whatever not
embedded I got confused is there other
work that one can do in these events
without per other than removing the
large Woody material um during the
during the event itself for instance if
you have a bridge abutment that is
failing and you need to put large rock
material in front of that to prevent
that from getting worse you can do that
during event and Report out after so yes
the rule is in place en nbwt
3155 if during the event there is
something taking damage if a structures
Foundation becomes exposed because the
river has a road Ed to it you can place
material in front of that structure in
order to reinforce that foundation and
tell us after those rules are in
place follow up follow up there was also
discussion and in the letter about
emergency permits emergency
authorizations I wondered is that uh
permit available to complete online and
do you have a time frame like how long
it takes for you to respond to it it is
a onepage form that you can file online
we also take them as phone calls
frequently come in as phone calls and
emails where we'll usually ask them to
do the form just so that we have
logistical information like who's the
contact
person um where is it uh brief
description of what you'd like to do and
we attempt to turn those
around within 24 to 48 hours um we are
actually they currently I think the max
maximum time that we allow ourselves by
rule is 5 days but frankly you're an
emergency we're going to look at these
things and frequently we'll turn them
around faster because you might not have
five days worth a wait thank you
appreciate
it anyone else representative rung then
representative
gby thank you Mr
chair and thank you Miss Force for
taking my question um what you've said
you've described seems very reasonable
um very um attentive to the needs but
yet I I hear representative Aaron and my
heartbreaks for those people who are
suffering um the devastation during a
flood so where's where's the how can we
bridge that
disconnect um in what you're saying and
what their needs are you you said you
know you're looking I mean can is there
a solution you prop
posst the Department's what the
department is already working on again
is a we're trying to develop online
tools so that people can immediately go
in you know whoever the town official is
can bring in some photos and location
data and someone in a town office can be
doing this while they're out doing the
work that is the after action
reporting um we're trying to work with
HSM to work on better fact sheets we
need to develop better
education um frankly we need to develop
tools that help towns
identify their infrastructure weaknesses
on their stream
Crossings so that they can look
for sequencing and prioritization and
how things should be repaired or
replaced um so many times in these
events undersized Crossings
non-maintained Crossings are where this
problem is
it's not that they're not maintained or
they're undersized because the towns
don't
care um and I say this as this is what I
we hear when folks contact us the pleas
that we are hearing from those who are
calling
us the town didn't have money to replace
it you don't have a lot of funds right
now since
2020 the the cost of building the cost
of labor
materials is astronomical it is
skyrocketing um that is more often than
not what prohibits corrective or
preventative measures it's not just
because they need to get a permit a
structural replacement for us is a
permit by
notification structural replacement with
upsizing on a major on a on a large
stream or a river yeah at that point
it's a little bit more more than a
permit by notification but we do
everything we can to streamline the
permitting of um expanded
Crossings because it is an environmental
gain for us it does the environment no
good for these things to fail so our our
Focus right now in in solving this
problem and unfortunately we're already
well behind the game and I when I say
that I don't just mean Dees I mean as a
state um there are so much damage to be
repaired and not enough people it seems
to do
it and not enough funds to pay for it
that's what we hear um we have already
from the standpoint of
Dees the most effective thing that we
can sometimes do is get out of the way
and we have rules that have done that to
the best of our ability they're there um
um the things that we hear about funding
and
Manpower that's beyond
us who
representative thank you Mr thank you
again for taking my question um
definitely the the thing that stuck out
to me was the um the concern um in your
testimonies is the concern over you know
how are things going to get paid for and
the fact that this may um in inhibit the
ability to apply for FEMA funds can I
can you describe for me the process of
how you know following a natural
disaster um the the Army Corps of
Engineers permit is issued and then the
the FEMA funds
follow so hm would be better to speak to
this than I would and what we have
learned through the last six months to
probably now it's
probably closer to 18 months time
flies um FEMA has changed some of their
reporting requirements so what we find
frequently now is as part of a FEMA
application for funds they need written
verification that the work that was
completed complies with environmental
law within the state and the Army Corps
we have a general permit with the Army
Corps issued to us every five years the
most recent was issued August of August
SE seber of last year September 29th of
last year so that's valid for another
four years 6 months if you have an
emergency authorization or you have
paperwork indicating that you qualified
under
315 05 uh actions during an emergency
then that satisfies the Army Corps
General
permit so that can be pointed to so the
important part is getting that paperwork
into folks hands the other thing that we
are frequently
seeing is that they need paperwork that
says it wasn't jurisdictional it's not
just that we're reporting now that this
was in jurisdiction and it meets the law
which means it would be under our
agreement with the Army Corps but they
also now sometimes need paperwork saying
that this wasn't in our jurisdiction at
all which has increased our need again
for this
online an easy online filing system that
people can come to us with so that we
can look at it and sometimes simply
issue an acknowledgement yep you did
work and it didn't need a permit because
it wasn't in
jurisdiction so it's documentation is
key for a followup thank you um I'm I'm
trying to understand as well the piece
about you know how the FEMA funds flow
to the homeowners or the property owners
or the municipalities that are
impacted that is a question for HSM I
know what HSM needs from us to complete
the applications but when it comes to
the actual
dispersement or applications for Aid
that is that is their
territories Yeah question quick one
thank you chair and thank you for your
uh testimony I just have a a question
and I apologize if you've already Co
covered this but representative Aaron
was talking about you know uh the idea
of working and clearing streams during
you know you you referenced immediate
aftermath
but nobody's going to how what does that
mean exactly immediate aftermath
and did you cover that I'm sorry so for
the immediate aftermath for
us we're still working with people and
we are still getting
requests for the latest uh gorum event
so for what it's worth we're still
functioning is if we're in the immediate
aftermath of in some cases the December
21st flood event um as well as the early
January we are
not we recognize that the greater the
disaster the longer it takes for you to
discover some
things so we are still receiving
requests for emergency authorization and
processing them as emergency
authorization requests and not requiring
full permits as as things come in so
just quick follow up followup up um Okay
so so to clarify um this pretty much
whole year could be the immediate
aftermath and as I as I said we're
actually still taking we are still
receiving and accepting after action
reports for work that towns did in July
of
um not necessarily permitting new work
but we're still taking it as their
reporting because they were so behind
and getting things done
um depending on the rain events it's
like a it it's almost like a rolling
action across the state as Things become
available the rules allow us to continue
to keep this open um I'm sorry if that's
not quite what you're looking for
but just I'm sorry this is the last one
so you know and I I just just because
you know
representative so you know a late person
reading immediate aftermath is not going
to think this could pertain to the whole
year because that's not what immediate
aftermath means I guess my question is
is there anywhere like a website on your
website clarifying that this is okay
immediate aftermath oh it's really
expanded uh much more than usual like
our rules require that you report to us
within five days of your discovery of
the
need
so if for
instance
Berlin doesn't Discover that they have a
ruptured pipeline that they definitely
need to get into the water to
fix if it happened six months ago but
you just discovered it now as long as
you report it to us within five days of
Discovery we're going to issue an
EA for that case if you reported it six
days after we're probably going to ask
you what took you so long would still
issue the EA because environmentally we
would prefer that that damage get
corrected as quickly as
possible thank
you anything else anyone else further
questions thank you very much thank you
your
time barara
RoR from theam Association of
conservation
commissions yes thank you very much for
the opportunity to provide comment on
House Bill
1121 my name is Barbara RoR and I'm the
executive director at the New Hampshire
Association of conservation commissions
and nhacc is a nonprofit organization
working to support conservation
commissions so that they can be
successful in protecting their local
natural
resources and we are opposed to this
bill um because we believe that this
bill is not necessary um because of
reason stated by um Dees already um Dees
does have a process in place called the
emergency authorization and that will
address heal um threats to Public Safety
public health during a natural disaster
and I've heard from a few towns that
have used this process and they thought
it was fine and I believe you have a
letter from Hampton which um does state
that they've gone through the emergency
authorization process and felt it was
fair speedy and again there was the the
costs weren't associated with that
permit um they are required to to you
know the applicant for the Emergency
authorization does require um a plan but
we believe that that's very important
because um certainly having some
oversight in the restoration ensures
Public Safety often times these
well-intended cleanups can really cause
issues to abutters or Downstream effects
if the work is not done properly so that
really is de's role to ensure that this
work is done properly and without any
sort of paperwork or notification I mean
know a onepage form at least is that
notification and documentation so that
you know if FEMA comes forward we all
the things are done properly um and
again I also have concerns about
jeopardizing the FEMA funds if um this
permit deviates from what the Army Corps
of Engineers is requiring so I think
that's you know part of the unintended
consequences of this bill is
is the likelihood that there's going to
be a lot of work that's not done
properly is out there because the
language is vague as well as you know
risking some of our FEMA funds um and
that can really be I'm sure scary to a
lot of towns um
I would also like everybody to keep in
mind that um really it's New Hampshire's
Wetlands that play a critical role in
mitigating our flood waters and they
help retain and store water during our
extreme weather events so it's really
important we protect these resources and
our our streams and our shorelands are
all part of that water system that we
really believes critical to have
oversight to have documentation and to
to do things properly and again I've
heard from several towns that have done
this process the emergency authorization
and felt it was actually you know
Fair easy and you know helpful because
Dees is really the best you know source
of um advice and information in these
kind of of you know restoring a a
streamed so that's who you want to go to
um and I and I you know I I wish you
know this was easier for everybody and
that you could just go you know take a
backhoe out well I don't wish that but
that you could just take a backo out but
you know I understand that that's you
have to do things um quickly and perhaps
you know nhac could work more closely
with Dees to help educate towns that
this process is available and here's how
we can expedite this work for you um
because it is unfortunate if you you
feel as a a land owner your your
property is threatened and you feel like
you have no options there but but again
I think if you get familiar with what is
available and and you understand the
role that Dees plays in this that you'd
be more apt to to choose the emergency
authorization and then go through an
after the fact permit if necessary so
that's
um basically our viewpoint on this I'd
be happy to answer any questions
um if if there's any from the committee
thank you any questions for members of
the
committee no thank you very
much final uh card I have is mareda
Hatfield from The Nature
Conservancy thank you very much uh my
name is Meredith Hatfield and I do
policy and government relations for The
Nature Conservancy in New Hampshire we
are part of a global
organization um and we've been working
in New Hampshire for over 60 years on a
range of environmental issues um this
really has been a quite sobering hearing
um what we're facing in New Hampshire
with um extreme weather and the um
increasing frequency really is something
that is affecting all of
us um we do have concerns with this bill
um and I I agree with a lot of what um
Miss RoR said so I won't repeat that um
but wetlands and temporary and perennial
streams um provide many benefits um
within our ecosystems and as she pointed
out actually can help us um with dealing
with with this increased uh
precipitation and with
flooding one thing that um I wanted to
specifically point out that Dees said is
that we are behind and we agree and I
actually wanted to commend to you a
Senate bill that I hope will make its
way to your committee
which establishes um the state
adaptation and resilience Council that
would actually give us a chance to pull
together agencies um including Dees and
hscm to consider some of these issues to
look at are we coordinating well our
people our land owners Farmers business
people municipalities are they aware of
these processes um are we aware as a
state of what is coming and what our
needs are and are are we prepared for
that um so I would agree that we should
um use the processes that exist and not
rush into making changes U before really
carefully considering the needs and the
uh potential impacts and one last thing
I wanted to mention is we are actively
working with do um to help them
identify new ways of building culverts
and finding um additional Federal
funding so that we can build um the
culverts of the future so that we can
try to avoid these situations um as we
have to accept all this uh additional
precipitation thank
you any questions members of the
committee representative
D I don't know I'm a little confused
you're talking about culverts and yet it
seems as though when I'm
first thought of this bill it seemed
like a tree falling into the stream that
I could pick up maybe and yeah you're
talking about all these other things of
bridge of butts butt BS and everything
so I don't see how those two things come
together what I don't understand here so
actually there was a a story in the
paper um about the last storm that we
had um and uh a family in Lowden that is
um experiencing extreme flooding on
their property and it's resulting from a
culvert so I think the one of the
challenges that was pointed out earlier
is that our public infrastructure is
sometimes um contributing to some of the
things that private land owners are
facing um and there's a real need to
address that and to not be um rebuilding
infrastructure the way we have been
doing you know maybe for hundreds of
years but really thinking about um what
are our future needs um so that's why I
raised
it Darby for a question thanks this
thank you Mr this isn't so much a
question as do you have a copy of that
testimony I didn't see it online I have
not submitted it but I will thank you
thank
you any other
questions seeing
none representative R wrong um Mr chair
I don't have a question but um if if
someone's going to submit online
testimony they only have until midnight
tonight is that correct midnight of the
day of the
hearing yeah I think so yeah okay yes
thank thank you thanks for the reminder
by
ACC acclamation that's that's the right
answer
but uh so is anyone else seeing none
than I guess she gone already thank you
very much uh there's no more qu no more
pink cards I will
declare House Bill hearing house bill
11:21 is
adjourned thank you very
much
uh we will be uh we will be hearing all
of these bills that we had
today and with the exception of
one
huh that's
right uh
no at the uh we have we have a caucus uh
representative
hor representative
Horan